よろしくお願いします
大変遅くなりましたので
早速今日のお話を始めたいと思います
あの 今日の話は この成功というのはどういうものかと
ブッダの教えから見るんですね
ですから 皆様もとっくに人生を成功する方法をご存知だと思いますけど
そうするとお釈迦様の話を聞いてがっかりするかもしれませんだけど
お釈迦様も一応人生成功する方法っていうのを教えてるんです
それで仏教から見れば
この道徳倫理っていうものは
幸福と成功っていうのはね
それは道徳倫理から始まりますよ
いわゆる私の言葉で言えば
人間の幸福の生みの親は道徳であるということになるんです
別にそこはそうですかと認めなくても結構です
まあ本当かな？と思っても構いません
道徳なんかえらい迷惑じゃないのかと
もう成功することの反対ではないかと思われた
思われても構いません
ですから これから仏教では道徳というものはどんなことかなと
本当かなということを考えておきます
はい 突然ちょっと内容たくさんありますので
いきなりもう中身に入ります
それで集中して聞かなくちゃという道徳を守らないと何もわからなくなります
人を言うことは真面目に聞くという一つのモラルなんです
まあそういうことで まあちょっと集中して聞くことにはなりますが
まずこの大胆なタイトルで完璧に優れた人って誰でしょうか？と
これは長部経典の第 4番目の経典
これすごい長いです で
ディガーニカヤ ソーナダンダ・スッタっていう経典がございまして
その経典のエピソードを
経典の中身を今日紹介します
ソーナダンダという名前のバラモンの長老が世尊に会うんです
このソーナダンダというのはものすごい有名人で
この当時で このお釈迦様がこの経典を書かれたその地方で一番トップクラス
とにかくインドの歴史の中に入っている
この偉大なるバラモン人の中の一人なんです
だからかなり有名なんです
有名だけではなくて もうたくさん弟子たちがいて
自分の学派 学校もあって
自分の伝統の それからまあブラマン教ではもう大物
当時のバラモン教を支えていたのは
このソーナダンダとか
また何人かのバラモンたちがいたんです
そういう人々の中の一人なんです
この人はお釈迦様に会うんですね
自分の地方にお釈迦様がいらっしゃるんです
いらっしゃったら お釈迦様のお話をざーっと広げちゃって
すごい方がいるんだそうと
ブッダと言うんだよと
また もうものすごい若く出家して
他の宗教家とは随分違いますよとかね
教えはすごいやと いろいろもう言葉を広げたんですね
それでソーナダンダさんがさっさと行って会わなくちゃいけないんだと
と決めたんですね 決めたら
他のバラモンの長老たちも何百人いますけど
何かんだけど あなたこそインドで一番トップクラスの人ではない
だから釈尊がお願いして
あなたのところに来たのではありません
あなた あんなもう出家して住んでいる家もないね
あっちこっち歩いて回っている人をね
あんた会うのは仕方がないというと
ソーナダンダさんが それは違います
人を褒めることっていうのは
一つはリストがありましてね
お釈迦様も我々と同じく
ものすごい家柄の人である
それで若いうちに出家したんだと
我々とは違って 一切財産を両親の意志に逆らってすべて捨てて出家したんだと
それで楽に達しているんだという
いろいろなことを言ってね
だからどう見ても我々より優れているんだから
私たちは釈迦さんに会わなくちゃいけないんだと
で その中でも最後の決まり文句で言ったのは
釈尊が偉い人で 遠くから来た
我々の方に遠くから国というのは
お客さんである それでヒンドゥーブラマン教で
この客イコール神なんです
今もその習慣はジワジワと残っているんです
だからインド文化系の国々どちらでも客は神という感じで思ってはいるのです
しかし 日本ではお客様は神様ですよということとはまるっきり違うんです
正反対です 勘違いしないでください
日本ではお客様は神様ですよ
というのは何かもう取りたいんですね
ただお客様のポケットを狙っているんですよ
財布を それが反対なんです
お客様とは神様ですから
自分が直々神様にお奉仕するんです
だから人間 神様を信仰しているんですけど
見たことはないんですね
だから 客として来る人は誰であろうとも
神として見なして奉仕をする
それでその人はすごく喜んで
すごい気持ちよくいて帰れるようにしてあげる
守ってあげたり 全部面倒見止めてあげたり
ご飯をお食事を入れてあげたりとかね
病気になっていたら治療したりとか
何でもする 奉仕する だから私たちにとっては釈尊は客であると
だからあなた方何言うのかと
客に不礼を奉仕するのは我々の宗教ではないだろう
最後にそれ言ったら みんな黙ってでお釈迦様に会うんです
だからこの人にお釈迦様に会うことは大変でしたよ
それで長い経典は省略して言いますけど
この人は大勢の人々と一緒に仏様に会いには行ったんだけど
途中でもうもうもうもうといろんなことを妄想しているんですよ
本人が釈尊はすごい人だと知っているんです
だからこう考えるんです
もしかするとお釈迦様が私にどんな質問をするでしょうかねとか
で 私に答えられなかったらどうしようかと
あるいは私が釈尊に何かどんな質問をしようかなと
それでもし私が質問するだって来ると
お釈迦様がバラモン あなたの質問の仕方が間違っているんだよと
そういうふうに質問したらいけませんよ
と言われたら最悪やと
で 私が恥かければもう大変だと恥をかけると
バラモン人 この人々はみんな私のことを批判するんだと
そこで私の名誉がなくなるんだと
この名誉がなくなることは
名前をちょっと傷つけることというのは私にとって大変だと
なぜならば 自分の偉大なる財産が自分のこの名前で得たものであると
あまりも有名人で凄い人だからということで
いっぱい王様やらみんなもう彼に必要なものをあげているんですよ
だから大富豪富豪家なんですけど
富豪家になったのはこの
名誉のおかげなんですね
だから私の 面子が潰れたらどうしようかと
もうとんでもないことになるんだぞと本人がずっと心配するんです
それでお釈迦様のところに行っても
本人がじーっとどうしよう
どうしよう 大変なことになったとかね
と考えているんです しかし
この何 100人いるバラモン寺の中で
本人が長老で一番前に座って
本人が喋らなくちゃいけないんです
で 喋れない どうしよう
どうしようと考えているんです
自分の身のことはもう財産のことをね
これがなくなったらどうしようかという心配でね
まあ別にそんなに悪い心配でもないんですよ
誰でもね 仕事がなくなったら別にどうって
ないんですけどね 楽々でいられますけど
問題はね 収入がなくなるでしょ
だから仕事をクビになることには誰も心配しませんよ
本当の心配は収入がなくなるんです
それが心配するんですよ
それは当たり前でしょうに
そこ 収入がなければどうやって生かすんですかね
子供にどうやって食わさせするんですかね
だからやっぱり誰でも自分の収入のことを財産のことを心配するのはごく普通
当たり前のことで だからこの人もたくさん弟子たちがいて
学校があって もうバラモン人の面倒を見なくちゃいけないし
もうだからかなり金が必要なんですね
だからそれがなくなったら全部終わりますよ
それで困っていたんですね
しゃくしゃくとわかったんですね
この人はまあこういうこういうことで妄想してかなり困ってるんだと
じゃあ何かまあ助けてあげなくちゃいけないんだと
思ってお釈迦様が じゃあ私はこの人の宗教について質問
私が質問すれば 本人がプロ中のプロだからね
喜んで答えるだろうと
そういうわけでお釈迦様が質問するんです
それはお釈迦様の質問なんですね
お分かりでしょうね まあブッダの言葉だから誰でもわかります
でまあしかし パーリ語ですね
カティーヒパナブラームナアンゲヒサマンナガタンブラームナブラフマナンパンヤペンテブラフマブラームナヌースミーティチャワダマーノサンマワダイヤナチャパナムサーワーダンアパジェヤーティという
質問なんです
これなんかすごく長く感じるでしょ
これもパーリ語の文章主体になりまして
とても美しい文章で もし言葉がわかるならば
一遍に明確に理解できるようにという意識で書かれています
だからすごい読みやすいんです
理解もしやすいんですが
パーリ語がわからないんですね
これちょっと問題ですね
で 私はそんな日本語訳は上手じゃないんです
私はもうだいたいいい加減日本語にするんです
完全なバラモンだと正しく間違いなく真実として認定するにはいくつかの条件が必要だとバラモン教で説かれているのでしょうか？という質問なんです
そこでいくつかの言葉は強調してダブっちゃうんです
わざとパーリ語で はい
普通日本語にすると この人はバラモン人として完全だよと
無欠やと立派やと最高だと
みんながしっかりと事実に基づいて認定する
認めるとするならば どんな条件が必要でしょうかとバラモン人に聞くんです
これ バラモン人の宗教から聞くんですよ
あなた方はどんな条件が必要だと言っているのかというと
それなりの質問に答えられるのは
どんなバラモンにも答えられません
バラモン人の中でも超エリートで
教授たちの中でも教授でないと答えられない質問なんです
そんな質問されたら その旦那さんがものすごい喜んじゃって
やっぱり私に聞くべき質問を聞いているんだと
あの今までグヤグヤグヤグヤグヤグヤ悩んだことはひと欠片もなくて
心から消えちゃったんです
いきなりものすごい喜び
充実感を感じたんですよ
家を出たのは出たんだけど
家からずっと大勢の人々と一緒に歩いている途中で
スーッともうくったくた悩んでたんです
恥かけられたらどうしようかと
だから結構怖かったんです
お釈迦様に会うのは そういう怖いと思うのは
だいたいすごいインテリなんです
すごいインテリがもう震えるんだよ
お釈迦様に会う場合は
しかし 一般の人とは何のことなく
お釈迦様と喋ること お釈迦様
質問がありますけどとかね
ああそう で そういう感じなんです
だからお釈迦様はすごい方で
こういうものすごく知識人にとってはもう冷や汗が出ます
しかし 小さな子供では誰でも言いたい放題のことをお釈迦様に
お釈迦様は何のことなくそれで対応する
時々普通の人々はね 家のことやらね
うちの息子がいるんだけど
あれだらしなくてとかね
ああ そうですかねとか
そういうすごく優しかったんですけど
やっぱりその人に合わせて答えるんですからね
バラモン人は怖かったんですよ
怖かったんですけど お釈迦様が自分の宗教で
その上 自分のようなプロ中のプロが答えるべき質問を選んで質問されると
ものすごい大喜びで 自分の研究館活動ですから
そこで彼がすごくなんか自信満々の顔をして
大勢の人々のこと 自分のグループのことをこうやって見渡して
体ちょっと前に出して展示したんです
だからそこら辺書いてないんです
そこで私が注補として一つ入れたんです
それから我々の勉強 なんだ
この質問はそんなに大事でしょうかと
これ古い質問でしょ 立派なバラモンで誰ですかと
誰でもいいでしょ 我々
会ったこともないでしょ？バラモン人にね
はい これ注を考えてください
インドっていうのはちょっと大きい国なんですね
国の大きさっていうのは時代によって変わるんです
地理学的ではなくて精神的に変わるんです
今は我々にとって地球は小さいんですよ
アメリカに行こうとしたら
もう明日でも準備して行けますよ
皆様なら 私ならできませんだけどね
で もうちょっともう観光に行って
その場でチケット買ってでも乗れるし
まあビザは必要ですけど
これ ８時間  12時間でもう行ってるんですよ
だから地理的には同じですけど
我々の時代ではもうなんか精神的にも近いんですね
だからインドっていうのは大きいということは
今はちょこっと小さいかもしれませんよ
しかし 当時では昔ではね
皆様 アメリカという国があるということも知らなかったでしょ？皆様ではなくても
当時の人々は だからそういうことで
インドっていうのはかなり当時では大きい国なんです
だからインド人にとってはインドが世界なんです
中国人と同じなんで考えれば
中国人は世界っていうのは中国だと思っていたしね
ユダヤ人もそう思っていたしね
非常にその周りの人々だけで世界が成り立っているんだ
他人間いると知らなかったんです
そういうことで このインドの人々が
まあこれが世界であってと思っていて
神様がこのカースト制度で全て作ったんだと
それで神様がもう森羅万象を作って
人間は ４つのカーストでつくりましたと
それで一番トップのカーストは
神の口から生まれた自分たちバラモンカーストですと
だからバラモンの民族で生まれること自体のインドの世界では一番トップの人間だと
生まれたらそれで終わりと
もう最高の人だと言っているんです
そこで人々の精神的な仕事
いわゆる宗教的なことをやるのは我々の仕事と
神との関わる仕事は我々がやるんだよと
この口から生まれたということは
彼らが象徴的に言うんであって
この知識人なんですね
バラモン人は学問を握っていたんです
文字は読める 本は書ける
ですから 王様たちにもこういう知識人のアドバイスは必要なんですね
それ一つで だからヴェーダ聖典やら作ったりして
宗教的なテキストを作ったりして
それを歌ったりって言って人々に祝福したり
もう 神に代表して神に頼んだりとか
物事 そうやっていろいろ商売繁盛していたんです
だから神に何かをおねだりしたければ
もう直接は言えないんです
バラモン人に言わないといけないので
だからバラモン人が神に言うんです
そういう風にこの口を使っていたんだから
自分たちがバラモンの口から生まれたんだと
だから喋るならば 私たちは神だ
神様と喋りますよという風に言っていたんです
他のカーストはそれぞれカーストに決めている仕事をしなさいよと
カースト変えることはできないんだというふうに言っていたんです
で 聖職者あると締め締まった
それでこの質問の意味は
このトップグレードの聖なる人々の中で
なおさらトップグレードは誰ですか？という質問なんです
それが当然です バラモン人がすごいたくさんいたんだから
インド社会を 4つに分けて
一部バラモンだからもうかなりたくさんいるんです
みんな優れてるわけじゃないんです
だから自分たちの中ででもトップグレードになる人は誰でしょうかということの質問は
なかなか大事な質問なんですよ
そこで皆様は理解して
我々現代人がどう理解するのかという
この質問で扱っているのは
我々人類としましょう
人類の中でトップグレードの人々の中で
その上のトップだと 言うならば
条件は何なのかということなんです
そういうふうに思っちゃうと
かなり役に立ちますよ
この教えは 世界で一番優れている人々の中で
でもその上をまた優れている人は誰ですか？それでバラモン人はそういうふうに答えるんです
パンチャイコパンチャイボーゴートマンゲイヒサマンナガタブラームナブラームナパンニャペンティブラームナノスネーティチャッパダマノサンマワデーヤナチャパナムサワダハーパッデッイエ
完璧なバラモンだと 正しく間違いなく真実として認定するには 5つの条件が必要だとバラモン教で説かれているのですとと答えるんです
お釈迦様 それはね 条件が 5つなのよ
この条件 5つ揃っていると
トップグレードのバラモンになる
いわゆるトップグレードのも
その上トップだ 自信を持って答えたんですね
はい これから条件に行きましょう
イデコボーゴートブラフモノウボトスジャートホートマイブッダビクトーチェクッとクッとジャーティワディ
これ長い文章を縮めたんです
意味は 1 7代目まで母方も父方も純血のバラモンであること
生まれについて何も疑問がないこと
だから純血のバラモン人であることをはっきりしなきゃダメですよ
ですから この両方で 7代目までチェックするんです
他の血が混じってないのか
両親の場合  7代目までは純血なバラモンであることを
他のカーストの血が混じってないことですね
これってなかなか大変ですよ
もうもう難しいんですよ
我々は親とおじいさんは誰かと知ってますけどね
その上どんな人かと何やった人かわかりませんからね
で  2番目の条件 置きましょうね
パーリは  3つのヴェーダ聖典暗記して
言葉ごとに解説でき 儀式
儀礼などができて 偉大なる人の 30人の人相を打ち間違いいっぱいあります
もう慌てて作ったんだから
そこはどうしましょうか
皆様は編集者になって訂正
これはあの人相を知っていることです
私の日本語の能力はバレバレですからね
2番目の条件というのは
自分たちのヴェーダ聖典を学んでおかなくちゃいけないんですよ
ヴェーダ聖典というのは
だいたいは頭のいいバラモンの子どもたちは
小さい時からそれを学ぶと暗記するんです
それぐらいはだいたいもう30歳ぐらいになってくると終わってるんです
今のインドにそういう学校あるんですよ
子どもたちはもうその学校に止めてもらって
バラモンカーストのね
で 朝早く もう 4時  3時に起きて
もう気を分けて暗記することやら儀式習うことやら
まあそれから普通の学校の教育もさせますけど
それはちょっと時間短いし
それから子どもたちだからね
遊びもしますけど それで夜遅くまでまた暗記したりして
もう小さい時からね 始まるんです
だから このまあ大体 10歳
その辺りで始まらないと間に合わないんです
かなりたくさんあります
それで子供たちに なんであんた方はそんなことを普通の学校に行って遊んだ方がよかったんではないかとか聞くと
もうやっぱりこれで卒業すればね
もう世界どこでもバラモン人として雇われますよと
そうするとちょこちょこと儀式やったらかなり金が入るんです
だから職業は安定しているんだということで
子供たちが叱られているんです
それでこのバラモン人の中でヴェーダを暗記するだけじゃ足りません
このヴェーダ経典膨大ですけど
言葉 １個ずつ１個ずつ明確に分析して解説しなくちゃいけないんです
それも暗記するんです
それから歴史 またいろいろ学問を学ばなくちゃいけない
その上 あらゆる儀式のやり方
このマジックたくさんやりますよ
これ ブラックマジックもあるし
普通の祝福する祈祷するマジックもあるし
そういうものを学ばなくちゃいけない
かなり仕事のような だからそれ全部学んでこなくちゃいけないんだと
それで全て学んだら 最終的にこの ４つ
３つぐらいのバラモンの学学系統で秘密としての教えがあったんです
その秘密の教えは 全て学問を完了した人にのみ教えただけです
だから知ってる人はいない
それで知っていたら もう文句ない
この人はすごい人やってことになります
もう学問完了しているんだ
それが最後に書いていた
この偉大なる人の 30人の人相
このバラモン人の経典ではなくて
教えの中に これ仏教の解説ですけど
神々がお釈迦様ブッダが現れる前に
かなりもう 100年  200年
300年前になってくると
彼らの教えにこそっと入れておくんだと
内緒で そこで一部のバラモン人が覚えておるんだと
どういうことかというと
人類の救い主というかね
人々には一切の幸福の道を教える最高な人が人間として現れます
しかし どこで何者かわからないでしょう
その人を発見する方法として 30人の人相があるんです
だからこの稀なバラモン人たちだけ
この 30人の人相を暗記して
調べる方法も覚えていて言うんですが
見つかりたくはない そこでこのバラモンというのは学問を完了していかなくちゃいけない
どこまでかというと この 30人の人相まで完了しておかなくちゃいけないんだ
そこはなぜ 30人の人相を強調するのかというと
このソウナンダさんの弟子も一人
その後で それからもう一人
ここからさわっていったバラモン人と 3人が偉大なるバラモン人がお釈迦様を調べたんです
ブッダですと言うんだから
そんな簡単に認めませんよ
我々の教えでは三十二の教えがあるんだと
三十二の人相の教え それがないと
だから人相占いですよ
それがないと認めるわけがいけません
言うと 自分たちの偉い弟子にこうやって学問を完了している弟子たちに調べなさいと言ったところ
調べたんだ これ三回調べたことあるんです
調べたら まあ本人が人相だけ見ているんだから
お釈迦さんは何のことなく
ああそうかということで見せてあげるんです
で 三十二はお釈迦様に揃っているんです
あるバラモンが三十二は揃っているだけじゃなくて
先生に報告すると この三十二は揃っていることはそんなのは当たり前だと
お釈迦さんにとっては
それよりすごいんだよと
お釈迦様の歩き方 座り方
食べ方 話し方 衣の着方
そういう二十四時間 私は三ヶ月間チェックしたんだよ
ちょっと手を洗っただけを見ても驚きますよと
あの完璧さよ 外でお釈迦様はご飯食べたりするしね
もう昨日したあれとかね
それご飯召し上がったところで
ご飯食べた鉢をね 洗って水を捨てるんですよ
それでまあ外だからポーンと捨てればいいでしょうに
その時もとても丁寧に
この生き物の体に触れないように
もう草とかね 生きてる草とか
そういうものにも触れないように
何もないところで ものすごくゆっくり綺麗に水を流してあげる
その時もちらっと飛び上がったりはしませんよ
水が飛んで鼻帰ってきて
誰か体に触れるとか それもない
それだけでも見たらびっくりしますよ
それで足の運び方とか
そうやって説明したことがあるんですよ
だから先生 先生は八十歳でしたけどね
先生 早く行って会ってくださいと
で その静楽というドラマに出てくる
まあ本人がだったら行くぞと言って
会って悟りに至するんです
そういうことだから この三十二の人相はまあちょっと入れてあるんです
ここでバラモンの学問と能力を語っているんですね
学問能力を完成しなくちゃいけない
はい 次に行きます 条件三
いくら見ていても飽きないほど美しい体と肌色があること
大変です それ ただ頭がいいだけってありませんよ
体形 格好は完璧でなければいけませんよ
まあどうせ男のことだから
美男でなければいけません
いくら学識があっても
美男でなければ認めないんですね
彼らは優れた人の中のトップには入れません
日本では頭がなくてもね
まあ格好だけ良ければね
彼女売れますけどね かえって頭がない方がいいと思ってるしね
条件四 四 道徳的な人間であること
優れた道徳を守っている経験があること
これシーラワーホーティ
ブッダシーリー ブッダシーレーナサマンナートというパーリ語なんです
すごい道徳的な人間であって
性格も完璧やって それから突然完璧を演じるんじゃなくて
長い間すごい道徳的に性格的な立派な人格者でいた経験が必要よ
ある日突然良い人間になったっても認めないんです
子供の時からもすごいしっかり者である
これは 4番目の条件 ブッダシーラとは
長い間道徳を守ってきて
熟練してきて 行動 これまた間違い
行動なっていうのはレベル高いというね
道徳が身についていることを意味します
早く早く消せます 条件 5番目
パンディトーチョホーティメーダーウィーパタノーチェワーデュティーヨワースジャンパンガンターナ
五 法要などで第一か第二の座に座を取れる理性のある賢者であること
これちょっとわからないんですね
注意を入れないと バラモン人の中でも尊敬するバラモン人がいるんです
バラモン人が尊敬する
尊い人であると 目上の人であると
バラモン人も宗教聖職者たちなんですよ
聖職者たちが自分たちでお坊さんだとかね
神父さんだとかね 尊敬する人を
なんです だからそこをその人が第一
第二座取るというんですね
いわゆる第一番目に座るか
もっと年上の人がいるならば第二番目に座ると
それで儀式儀礼やって尊敬する場合は
先にその人に尊敬して幼い者は差し上げたりする
その格を取ってなくちゃダメですよ
それだけではなくて 賢者でなければいけません
理性がなければダメですよ
そこで問題 学問 学識と知恵があることは同じではありませんね
二番目の条件は学問でしょ
で で で 何て言ったっけ
で 学問は習得しても頭いい人間でインドでは認めてなかったんです
頭がいいというのは別なものなんです
インドの学問はほとんど丸暗記
これで漢字はいいんですかね
文化ですか です 文化ですか
今は頭の悪い知識人が多いですからね
だからこの知識人で頭いいわけじゃないんですよ
もう飽きるほどもう頭が悪いんですよ
しかし すごい知識人なんです
私はものすごく嫌になっているところなんですよ
調べてみれば いい大学出て
もうアメリカの大学も出てとか
言うことは言うんだけども
頭の悪さ 判断の悪さ なおさらテレビに出るんだから
知識人と専門家と全国広げるんです
私は信頼できない最低の頭だよと
その上それがわからない市長さん
だから日本もだから大変ですよ
この頭いい だから学識を見ていろいろ仕事に入れるでしょうね
頼むでしょうに 結果は何ですかね
むちゃくちゃでしょうに
だからただ勉強しただけではもう仕事に雇うんじゃないんです
本当に頭がいいか悪いかということは別な世界なんです
それは仏教は知識と知恵とちゃんと区別しているんです
その習慣はインドでもあったんです
特別なことじゃないんですよ
これは事実ですよ アメリカにしろ
日本にしろ ただ単に学問的にいいわけでは良い人間にならないでしょ
時々大学は一流大学を出ていなくても
見事に仕事をしてみんなびっくりさせる人もいるでしょうに
だから本当の知恵っていうのは別なものなんです
わかりやすく言えば 自分の知識
いかに使えるのかということ
例えば音楽大学はトップクラスで卒業したっても
ろくに演奏できないならば
新しい作品を作れないなら何にもないでしょ
丸暗記した演奏を繰り返してやったってつまらないんですよ
で 音楽の場合はみんなびっくりするような
今まで聴いてなかったすごい曲を作ったりして
これまた聞いたらもう感動するわ
感動するわと言うならば
それが知恵のセクションなんですね
だから大臣に認定するためには
その管轄の中で教授を選びますよと言ったっても
大臣としては最低最悪になる可能性はいくらでもあります
大学の教授かもしれませんだけど
もうテキストを調べながら偉い授業をやっているかもしれませんだけど
実際 例えば経済学の教授が経済関係の大臣にしてしまったら違いますよ
経済学関係の大臣っていうのは
もう国の本当の経済を運営しなくちゃいけないんです
それから次に次にどうなるのかという判断まで出さなくちゃいけないんです
だから 日銀総裁よりもすごい仕事になる
日銀総裁は維持を現状を維持すればいいんです
政治家が次から何か問題が出てくる
どうしようか 例えば 石油が値段上がったり
食料の値段が上がったりすると
なんとかしなくちゃって政治家がなんとかしなくちゃいけないんですよ
政治家がいろんな国々と話し合ったりして
いろいろ対策を練って法で作ったり
決まりを作ったりしなくちゃいかないんです
だから 本当の仕事はそちらにあるんですよ
大学で授業しますよ これからもう食料の値段これくらい上がりますよとかね
統計的に見るとこうなるんだよとかね
あの国はこうなるんだよ
この国はこうなるんだよとか言うことだけは言えますよ
でもあなたどうするのかと
俺には関係ないんだよという話です
そんなこと言ったら ものすごく心臓がドキドキしてびっくりして怖くなるのは
実際のそのその係の大臣やら政治家なんですよ
だから被害を受けるのは一般国民だからね
大変ですよ ですから いつでも実際の仕事で
現場でうまく仕事できる人が知恵がある人なんですね
もっとわかりやすく言えば
問題が起きたらすぐ対応できる人
もっと明確正確に言えば
予期しなかったことが起きたら
予想しなかったらしなかったことが起きたら
知恵のある人は対応するんです
マニュアル見ている人はもう最悪
予期しなかったんだから
まあマニュアルにないでしょう
それが知恵ということなんです
だから一番必要なそれなんです
それってみんな認めないだけで
普通どんな国でもそれが機能はしています
昔私は聞いた話でね 田中角栄さんという総理がいたということで
なんかすごくくったくた批判されたみたいですね
大学は出ていない 一流の大学も出ていない
頭が悪い あれやこれやとかね
しかし いまだにその人が出た地方では
なんかすごい尊敬していると
しっかりやったと 彼にはもう一流大学出た経験がないんですけど
頭が働いてどうすればいいかと
そこでそこで考えて まあすごいしたんですね
そういうことで やっぱりこの形式的な学問では人は判断できません
あなたはそれをどう使うのかっていうことはとても大事なことだ
それは知恵ということになります
はい 帰ってきます それでバラモン人が条件 5つ言いました
お釈迦様の意見を言わなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことをお釈迦様は言うんです
この 5つの条件から 1つ減らして
4つの条件で完全たるバラモンだと認定することはできますか？とお釈迦様は
なるほど  5つあるんだということで
スワミダジこの 5つの中で 1つ減らして 4
つの条件でトップグレードのトップグレードで認定することができますか？という質問なんです
そこで自分の教えについて
スワミダジでの理解能力を調べているんです
だからお釈迦様はちょこっと調べるんです
そんなんがみんな 5つの条件だって言ってるんだからね
大向かいで言っているのか
自分ではっきりと意味理解しているのかということも聞いているんです
だから非常に中にそれ入ってるわけです
大向かいで言ったならば
そんなに過ぎてないんだろう
条件は 5つだよということで終わります
自分で理解しているならば
自分で答えを出す  です
条件を一つカットすることができますとバラモンが言うんです
このバラモンができますよと堂々と言う
一つはカットできる 美君という美君でいいか
美貌 美貌という条件を捨てましょう
美貌と人格は何の関係もないわけ
くだらないんだけど 捨てましょう
自分で答える この 4つの条件から一つ捨てて
3つの条件で完全なるバラモンだと認定することができますか？と
また次の日ですよね とお釈迦様に聞くと
なるほどよくわかりましたと
では その 3つ  4つの条件から一つまたカットして
3つの条件でトップグレードの人を認定できますか？と
できます ヴェーダ正典に通じていることという条件を捨てましょうと
ヒンディーマンターカリさんとこの人がいきなり学問を捨てるんです
すごいでしょう 本当です
学問がなくなってもいい
人間で生きていけます
それまた自分の宗教の学問なんです
ヴェーダ正典あんなの捨てましょう
あんなのがなくなっても大丈夫じゃん
自分は何をするんですか？と
本人も知っていて また自分が何にもないんだ
この 3つの条件から一つ捨てて
2つの条件で完全なるバラモンだと認定することはできますか？お釈迦様
何聞くんですかね もう見透まねになったんだから
もう一つ捨てましょうというのです
お釈迦様は バラモンはできますよ
生まれの条件を捨てましょう
生まれは何？何をするのでしょうか
バラモン人だというために
まあ最低母親父親でもバラモン人じゃなきゃ言えません
言えませんでしょうしね
常識では このバラモンじゃそんなのはどうでもいいんだ
捨てましょう 腹が立っているみたいです
それがそういう 条件 2つで立派な人間になるんだから
それでまあ決まっている質問で
この 2つの条件から 1つ捨てて
1つの条件で完全なるバラモンだと認定することはできますか？と
そこで微妙にこのバラモンバラモンという単語が
バラモン民族の一員ではなく
なんのことなく優れた人という意味に変化していくのです
バラモン族の人ではなくて
優れた人ということに
なんとなく単語の意味がもう発展していくのです
だから その段階の知らないうちに
バラモン バラモンというのはもう親がバラモンだからではなくて
人格的に優れているだからということにもなっている
釈尊サラ できません 一つの条件にすることはできませんと
三輪までは切っちゃったんです
最後の二つ これはできませんと
ノーヒダンボーゴーとも
知恵は道徳で清らかに完成になる
道徳は知恵で清らかに完成になるよ
あと 四と五は 道徳と知恵なんです
これは切れません 捨てられません
なぜならばお互い相互依存して依存していますよ
頭のいいことは道徳で完成する
道徳を守ることで頭が良くなる
セットなんです シーラパリドーターヒボーゴーともパンニャーパンニャーパリドータンシーラン
このパリドータっていうのは怪しい単語で
清らかになるっていう意味でもあるし
完成するっていう意味もありますからね
訳はできなくなったけど
やたーシーランタッタパンニャーやったパンニャータッタシーラン
道徳があるところに知恵がある
知恵がある人に道徳がある
道徳から知恵が現れる
知恵から道徳が現れると
ずっとこのバラモン人が言うんです
最後の文章は訳が入ってこないから
最後に書いているのは
道徳と知恵がこの世の中で最高たるものである
また ワンセットで切り離れることはできません
知恵と道徳はこの世で最も優れたものだというのですと
バラモン人が言うんです
お釈迦様じゃないんです
釈尊がご自分で語ら語られるバラモンに真理を言わせるんですよ
お釈迦様のするやり方なんです
自分でキャーキャーキャーキャーと真理を言わない
相手に言わせるんです
本当のことを だからこの場合もお釈迦様が教えたかったことは
ソーナンダさんに何のことも言わせるんです
答えたのはソーナンダさんなんです
もう議論とは成り立ちません
もうどうにもならないんです
お釈迦様は何も言ってないんです
質問しただけ だからそれはお釈迦様の偉大なところなんです
相手に押し付けることをしないんです
相手に質問して相手が答えるだけ
自分が言ったことはいい
そんなこと言ってないんだって言えないでしょう
それより私は反対だと言えないでしょ
それはものすごい平和的に説法する方法なんです
しかし この対話に異論が起きたんです
これで大変なことになったんです
バラモン人とお釈迦様が話し合っている間で
他の人々はから見れば
何のことなくこの人が仏教になっているんです
このソーナンダが これ認めるわけにはいきませんけど
どなたも聞いていただけだから
対話が二人で行ったんだから
みんな大騒ぎして大反対したんです
ですから 黒くしたんですけど
だからいろんなと ソーナンダがカーストも聖典も美貌も侮辱してブッダの教えに取り込むのだと批判を受けた
モラモン教ではモラモンであることは絶対条件で
もうそれから美貌はものすごい絶対条件で
ヴェーダ聖典は暗記するのは当たり前で
これ全部捨てたんだけど
この人は でも知恵と道徳だけ語るんだ
この人は何のことなくブッダの教えに飛び込んでるんではないか
と批判したんです 批判したら
お釈迦様はその時見事に助けてあげるんです
お釈迦様は何のことなく
はいはい わかりました
わかりました 君たちは静かにしてください
君たちが思うならば このソーナンダが馬鹿でアホで釈尊と対話できないんだと
能力なく まともな対話できるとあなた方やと
あなた方の教えについて思うならば
どうぞその旦那さんを黙っていてください
あなたが喋ってください
私と言ったら ソーナンダさんというのは
バラモンの中でもエリートの中でエリートでしょうね
この人々は家来みたいにこそこそと近寄っているだけなんですよ
先生 あっちへ行け 我々喋ります
できるわけないでしょうに
そんな学問ないでしょう
喋れないんです いい時代の先生がいないんだとみんな下がっちゃった
だったら黙ってなさいと
そういうことですね ソーナダンダが弁解
それでソーナダンダさんにまた立ち向かっていき始まったんです
お釈迦様は見事に守ってあげたんです
ほんのちょこっと言葉で
だからいかに仏教は理性使うのかと
なんであなた方はそう言うのかと
喧嘩にしないんですよ
私も道徳は正しいと思っていますよと
そんなこと言わないんです
ただちょこっとした論理で
どちらの方が頭いいかと考えてみてくださいくださいよと
もしあなた方はソーナダンダさんよりも理性があって対話できる能力あると思うのであれば
あなた方と私で喋るのは常識でしょうにと
だったら君たちと私も対話しましょうよと
いうことで みんなに事実やっぱりソーナダンダさんがすごい人だから
その人が対話するべきだと
すぐわかるんです それで異論が全部一発で消えるんです
それでソーナダンダさんがみんな黙ったら
お釈迦様 ちょっと待ってください
私が説明しますよと弟子たちにソーナダンダさんが説明するんです
私は聖典もカーストも美貌も侮辱するのではありません
私はそんなこと侮辱してないんだよ
あれ どう読むんですか？えっ？はい
私のいとこのアンガカを見なさいと
そこにいとこがいたんです
妹の息子 生まれはよろしい
私が両親も知っていると
この人はもう 7 代目まで純血な生まれだと
このいとこが だから妹の息子だから自分の家柄でしょうし
母方は結婚しているのは
それまたすごいバラモン系の人で
だから生まれはまぬっけり完璧に問題ないんです
聖典の条件もそろって満たしている
私が師匠でしたと このいとこがアンガカがサンヴェーデンヴェーダ聖典を丸暗記して注釈もできて
32 の人相まで知ってるんだよ
それで師匠は私でしたからね
確かに知ってます 条件そろってます
それから美貌 堂々と言うんですよ
君たちの間でこいつほどかっこいい男いるのか？この誰でものすごいかっこいいんだと
美しいんだと 男で 王政の人々の中で
ものすごいかっこよく輝いている体格なんです
だから条件満ちそろっているんです
しかし この子 乱暴者で窃盗する
盗みをする よこしまな行為をする
嘘をつく 飲酒する 最悪だ
あまりにも乱暴でいい加減で
人を殺すは もう酒飲むは
よこしまな女遊びするは
全くバラモン人の社会には入れない
入れられないぐらい性格最悪なんです
カーストも知識も美貌も何の役にも立ってないのではないでしょうか
だから自分のいとこだからね
ものすごく心配してるんですよ
自分が育てたんだから
自分の インドでは厳しいんですね
弟子たちっていうのはもう自分の子供のように愛情があるんですよ
師弟関係は向こうは その上もういとこでしょうに
なおさらもう可愛いんですよ
なのにあれほど教えているのに
何一つ役に立ってないんです
立派な人間になるために
あれほど学問を学んでいるのに
微塵も道徳的な人間になるために
まとめな人間になるには役に立ってないんだと
だから彼が言う 何のことなく
何の役に立つんですか？何の役に立つんですか？と言ったんです
自分の経験で いとこは人間らしからんんですよ
心配ですよ 出て行けと破門することもできないし
頭はいいし 勉強もできるし
しかし性格 浅いところで
はい それから道徳と知恵の関係
大体その経典だけでも今日の話はそれで終わりですけどね
あの 何を学んでも意味がないんですよ
じゃあ皆様は東大卒業だったら人殺しの仕事をあげる？じゃあ卒業はそれはありません
例えばまあ東大の教授でいたんだと
しかし人を殺してるんです
あ それでも大丈夫大丈夫
もううちの学校でも講義頼みますよとやるんですか？全てパーになっちゃいます
道徳破ったらすべて終わるんですよ
たとえ皇室で生まれたっても
その立場は変わらないでしょ
生まれつきだからね みんな尊敬していますよ
もし何か変なことやったら
やったった 生まれから滅せますよ
全部終わるんです 法律で裁かなくてはいけないんですよ
たとえ皇室じゃ 人でも殺したら時間でもしか
それで立場はどうなるんですかね
すべてなくなるんです
だから自分を守ってくれない
それが事実なんですよ
で それから知恵 ものすごい
もうアメリカでもありったけの大学出ていて
日本でも東大は出て あれやこれやとかね
もう博士号 10個ぐらい持っているのか
言ったっても 何か問題が出たところで
まあこれはもう紀元前の時代ではとかね
そういうことはエジプトでもありましたとか
そんなくだらんことを言っていたとしても
今起きた問題にはね 答えがなかったら何の役にも立たないでしょう
日本の経済状況が悪化したところで
国会でもうこういう経済関係の大臣が
まあこういう状況っていうのは
今もう温暖化問題であれで中東の戦争があるんだから
まあそういうことになりますからとか分析したって
何の役に立ちませんでしょう
そんなことは誰でも分析して調べることができるでしょう
問題はそうじゃないんです
どうしましょうかということなんです
だからそれで批判を受けますよ
立場がなくなるんですよ
日本の総理大臣 何人かもう早く辞めたことになったんですかね
最近でもね 福田さんの場合
人はもう若い 若いし 能力もあるし
立派な伊藤でしょうに
すぐ辞めることになったでしょうに
何でしょうか 家柄はよろしいし
頭もよろしいし 政治家として訓練もよろしいし
何の文句もなかったんです
しかし 知恵がないんです
頭が悪いんですよ 判断能力ないんです
決断できないんです こうしましょうとはできませんね
それで辞めることになるんです
もっと問題抱えている福田さんは全然病気にならないでしょ
あの前の方はね 病院に運ばれる羽目になったでしょうに
倒れちゃって 今もっと問題抱えてるんで堂々といいますからね
だからやっぱり必要なのはそれなんですよ
問題が起きたらどうするのかと
あらゆることを言われますけど
福田さんももうそれにちゃんと答えて
ニコッと笑って ちょっとしたことで民主党でしたけども
潰れて壊れる羽目になっちゃったんだから
だからまあ私はそれで一つ
国のリーダーとしては結構能力あると一応思ったりするんですね
よくやってるんだと だからそういうことと道徳があること
それでも福田さんも何か裏で何かやったとかね
バレたらもう辞めなくちゃいけないでしょ
だからよく覚えてください
自分の身を守ってくれるのは道徳なんです
それで自分の人生を成功に導くのは知恵なんです
判断能力なんです 問題が起きたらどのように解決するのかっていう
そのインスピレーションなんです
それがアイデアというんですね
日本語で一般的に だからそれは突然現れなくちゃいけないんですよ
この予測通りに世の中は動くわけじゃないんです
この原油高騰も一人にも経済学者は予測してなかったんです
調べたんです 誰にも いきなり出あがったんです
だからそれからどうするのかっていうことも問題なんです
そこで知恵がある人なら
もうその問題はすぐ解決します
はい 例えで説明してやります
このバラモン まだ経典なんですけど
この例えを説明します
これと言いますと 手で手を洗うように
足で足を洗うように 知恵は戒律で清らかになる
戒律は知恵で清らかになると
この 2つは不可分だということ
当時では手を洗う場合はこうやって手で手を洗うでしょ
皆さんもそうでしょ 手を洗う場合は手で洗うんです
そのように道徳と知恵っていうのは
お互い様きれいになるんだと
それで昔は足を洗う時でも
水をかけて足で足を洗ったりはする
そんな感じで一緒だと
倫理と道徳は人気者ではないと
じゃあこれから経典は終わりまして
まあ雑談に入ります 世間話に
あの経典で あれはあれ
だいたいあのところでは終わってないんですけど
バラモン人が何のこともなく知恵があったんだから事実を語ったんです
事実を語ったところで
何のこともなく 仏教なんです
仏教なんです お釈迦様は何もおっしゃってないんです
お釈迦様は最後に同じことをリピートするの
私もそう思いますと 私も知恵と道徳は不可分離やと思います
で 私も手で手を洗うように
足で足が足を洗うように
道徳で知恵を完了する
知恵で道徳を完了すると清らかになると言います
それでお互い様もうまく対話が終わったんです
次にお釈迦様は次の質問をするんです
では 相馬旦那さん この智慧を道徳を完成する
智慧を完成するということはどういう意味でしょうか？と言ったら
相馬旦那さんが お釈迦様
我々の知識はそこまでですと
道徳はいかに完成するのか
智慧はいかに完成するのかということは
お釈迦様の世界ですと
ですからお願いしますから
それから我々にそれを教えてください
バラモン人は知らないんだ
それからお釈迦様は道徳を完了する方法と智慧を完成する
それをずっと教えたんです
それで行でもあるんです
はい まあそれからもう一般論で皆様にも参加できると思いますけど
あの あんまり人気じゃないんですね
道徳は 世界は道徳の価値を無視しているんです
性格のいい人を馬鹿にするんですね
いかにへんてこりんなことやというと
アメリカの人だってもね
もう平気で我々にまでもうそんなことを破りなさいよと
アメリカ人になりなさいよという話ばっかりでしょ
我々の伝統を馬鹿にするわ
宗教を馬鹿にするわ しきたり習慣を馬鹿にするわ
親を大事にすることを馬鹿にするわ
それなのに大統領選挙に出た人がちょっと女の手を触ったことあったら
これ ２３年前でもいいんです
なんとか調べて調べて
その人は手をいっぱい横に上げて強引にインタビューして
ニュースっていうのは作ったもんだからね
事実じゃないんだから
それでニュースで流して流して
その人は降ろされる このクリントンさんを潰したのもその前はね
まあちょっとだらしないと
異性に対してはということで
しかし 完全に潰すことはできなかったんです
ちょこっとちょこっとみんな色々言われたんですけど
やっぱりこの人は立派な政治家で
道徳 その辺で道徳はしっかりしていたんです
国のために 国民には一番悪いことをしてなかったんです
法律を犯すことと それからもう頭がいいんです
すごい判断能力 だからモニカさんをインタビューしたインタビューを聞いたことがありますよ
それ聞いてると 質問する人はまああなたとか
あなたとはね いろいろ個人的にあれやったんですけど
その場合はこの国のこと
政治のこと あなたの職業のこととかね
ちょっといい仕事もらったりとかね
そういうことはあったんでしょうか？と
言うと 彼女があれほどクリントンさんに悪口言うんですけど
いえ  He was a real politician です
He is a real politician
彼が完璧な政治家ですよ
裏で個人的にだらしないことするんですけど
その時は国の話 政治の話
まるっきり持ってくる
その話を出すことさえもできないんだよ
その 一行を聞いて なるほど
あなた方はもうどうでもいいことガヤガヤやったってもね
人は潰せませんねと 立派な人
だからそこら辺で道徳を破ったならば
もう刑務所かもしれませんね
そういうことですよ だからこの結局は事実は事実なんです
だから我々 それなんで認めないで否定するんですかね
だらしない方がかっこいいとか
いろいろ女に手を出すことがすごいかっこいいやとか
なんでそう思うんですかね
他人が守るもの 道徳について
みんな他人に厳しく設計するんです
我々は道徳っていうのは
これは他人が守るもの
俺が守るものじゃないと思っているんです
だからみんなギャーギャー他人に言うんですね
他人が何か過ちを犯したら
大騒ぎして批判する 自分で守るものだと思わないんですね
道徳というのは これは他人の話で
私には関係ないんだと
なんで嘘をつくななんて言う人は
自分では嘘つくでしょう
道徳は嫌われる欠かせないものだと思わないことに
だからですよ 道徳は嫌いになっている
嫌ですね そういう話を聞くと
学校の先生が嘘をつくなとか道徳聞いて子供たちにバレてるならば
先生は結構嘘をついているんだとバレてると聞きたくないで
そんな話は だからずっと我々にも年上の人々から厳しく道徳を言われたでしょう
言われるたびに嫌に反感を取るんです
やりたくなるんです 喧嘩するなよと言うと
喧嘩してやろうと思っちゃう
何やこれ なぜでしょうかというと
本人が自分でやりたくない
あなたがでやるなよと言うんだからね
この道徳は他人が守るものだと思っているんだからこそ
世の中で次の世代も道徳を重んじるようになってないんです
だから若者が犯罪を起こしたり
だらしなくて もう引きこもりで仕事に行かないでだらしなく
すごい人生をダメにしているでしょう
大人が悪いんです するとそういう同じことを言われちゃって
じゃあやってやるということになってしまう
簡単に だからすごい大きな問題なんですね
自分で守る気はないのに
他人に説教する人は次の世代にも悪影響を与える
道徳を笑いものにするんです
だから我々は道徳を笑いものにしているんです
大人の世界が道徳を笑いものにして
次の世代へ道徳をしようとしていて
それでなおさら非道徳的な社会になっていって
世界が壊れてしまいますね
道徳を犯す人よりも社会にダメージを与えるんです
ですから 自分で他人に説教すると
自分が本当に悪いことをやっているんですよ
自分が嘘をつきながら
他人に嘘をつくなよと手柄になと言うと
その人は徹底的に嘘をつく人間になって
だから一番悪くするのを誰が犯しているんですか？この説教みたいと思う
アッターネームパタマンパティルーペニウェーセーアタンマノーサーセーネキッセーパンディットというのはブッダの言葉があるんですね
これは法句経にあるんです
自分は先に実行してから他人に指導する賢者は批判は受けませんと
だから道徳のポイントは
まず自分がやってみて
いいことだから人に教えてあげる
それだったら真面目に聞いてくれる
聞かなくても教えてくれ
教えてくれと聞くんです
時々テレビでも出るでしょう
この成功の秘訣はなんでしょうかと
すごい大成功の人々をインタビューするでしょうね
テレビだけじゃなくて
私が読む外国の雑誌の中でも
結構いろんな有名な大会社
そういった人々やらね
インタビューするんですよ
だからそう言って 私では小さい時はこんなことで
ものすごいお金がなくて
もうもう借りたアパートで
もう父親逃げられて お母さんがこれこれぐらい苦労してとかね
そういう話をして まあこれぐらい人がいて
あんたどうやってそれぐらいもう世界的な大きい会社を作ったんでしょうかと
なんでみんな真面目に仕事してるのかと
じゃあ私もこういうこういう決まりがあります
よく見ると全て道徳なんですね
私は自分の社員たちはみんなパートナーだと思っているんだよと
私も本気で 私は社長ではなくて
みんなと一緒のパートナーだよと
そこで平等ということ出てくるんですね
だからパートナー一人一人として自分が何をするべきかと
そういう考える自由があるんだよと
そこで誰かが考え方 何か新しいものを出したら
みんな一生懸命 それについて考えて
実行してあげる方法に持っていくんだよ
だから失敗しませんよ
そういういろんなアドバイスは全部道徳的な話なんですよ
経済的な話じゃないんです
あ これは私はもうオックスフォード大学出ていたんだから
これは大学で教授たちから学んだ知識は一人も言ってないです
全部性格のこと どう人と付き合うのか
どのように人を扱うのかっていうところで成功は決まるんです
いわゆる人間が自分のことを信頼するのか
自分はリーダーとして認めるのかということで
自分の命令は気持ちよくありがたく聞くのかと
命令なら聞くんだぞっていうのは話になりませんよ
命令されたら喜んで喜んで
私に頼まれたんだからやってやるぞという気分にならなきゃダメなんです
だからもう社長に言われたんだから
こせこせと言い合いで仕事をする場合は
やっぱりいい関係できてないんですよ
その会社が倒産しないということがなくなっちゃうんです
社員が これ 私に社長に直々言われたんだよとかね
すごくこの宝物のように感じて
これちゃんとやってあげなくちゃとか
申し訳ないとか あの方にとか
あれほど立派な人 そんな気分になると
そういう会社なんか倒産しませんよ
だから このお釈迦様がそれを随分簡単に言っている
まず先に自分をやってください
それから他人に言ってください
それで道徳はなんでないのかというと
この自我が問題なんですね
皆エゴイストなので 自分のこと以外興味はありませんね
手段は何であろうとも
自分が成功すればよいのだというのは本音ですね
人間の 道徳を守ると自分が損すると思っているんですね
しかし 他人を無視する
思いやりのない罪を犯す人は
自分の行為で破滅になるのです
だから 人間の考えと事実とは正反対です
人間が私が得すればそれでいいんだと
自我ばっかしなんです
人のことを構っていられる場合じゃないんだよ
そういうことで手段を選ばず商売に手を出して
いろんなことに手を出して悪いことをしちゃうと
みんなに嫌われちゃって
誰も協力しないことになっちゃって
同じ自分が雇った人々でも
できれば会社を倒産させたいんですね
できれば内部告発したいとすごく思っていて
内部告発したところで会社が倒産する
だから道徳ないっていうことわかるでしょうに
日本でもね  1年どれぐらい会社倒産するんですか？全部道徳ないんだから
法律を犯してるんだから
一般人黙ってたんだからでしょ
飛騨牛とラベル貼るんだけど
もうとんでもない 3種類の牛乳で牛肉で
牛乳会社もそういう問題を作ったし
うなぎの会社も作ったし
それからもう建築の関係でもそういうことが起きたし
だからもう契約書を書いても信頼できない世界でしょう
この会社にこの仕事を頼まなくいけないっていうことなんですか
その契約書も書くんだけど
その会社が何かやっちゃうんです
そうするとこちらのお金が全部なくなったりして
もう終わり 会社が倒産したんだからといって
こちらの損害はそのままでしょう
だから世の中をよく見て事実を見てみたら
自我で壊れるんですよ
何としてでも儲かればいいやと
ということはないんですよ
だからエゴがあると自己破壊するんですよ
自我が自分の幸福を壊す代物です
だから自我があるんだから
道徳は守りたくないんです
しかし 自我が自分を破壊するんです
それから精神病気と道徳
無知 欲 怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ
混乱などがあるからこそ
人は道徳を無視するんです
まず人はなんで道徳を無視するのかと
欲がある 怒りがある 憎しみがある
嫉妬がある 落ち込んでいる
自信がない 人を恨んでいる
そういう性格で悪いことするでしょ
あるいは頭がおかしい
混乱している 道徳を無視して生きる人の精神病は徐々に悪化するのです
だから上書いたのは精神病気なんです
精神病ですよ 怒りがある
欲がある 嫉妬 憎しみ 恨みあると病気です
それで道徳まで犯しちゃうと
どんどん病気が治るわけないでしょ
人に嫉妬して何かしたんだからといって
そこで相手が負けるわけでもないし
自分がなおさらダメになるでしょ
だから道徳を犯すたびに
自分の精神病気はどんどん悪化するんです
道徳を守ると心の病気が徐々に治るんです
嫉妬しないことで 怒らないことで
欲張らないことで 嘘を言わないことでいると
たとえ病気であっても
病気がどんどんどんどん治っていくんです
だから なんで世界が道徳が嫌いし
誰も守ろうとしないし
それでひどい目にあっているのにも関わらず守りたくはないんです
とにかく理由をつけて道徳破ろうとしているのです
日本の仏教の歴史みたいなものになっているんです
日本の仏教の研究家たちは何を研究したかというと
道徳を否定するために何するべきかということを考えたんです
酒に般若党というんだからね
だって仏教はパンニャーの教えですからね
禁止しています お釈迦様
自分たちは道徳を破っているんで
破ったっても申し訳ないと言えばそれで問題解決しますけど
私が悪かったと言えば
そのままいい 私が正しいということを言うためにあらゆる方法をするんですね
でもいまだに酒飲むべきやということは証明してないんですよ
日本のお寺は 偉い若者たちがいっぱいいるんですけども
弘法大師とかね もう日蓮とかね
すごい頭が悪いし で だったら証明してください
自分が言っていることは正しいと
証明もできないでしょ
証明もできないですね
道徳 だからまあ そういうことっていうのは世の中によくあることで
日本の仏教は冷凍で出しただけで
もうみんなそうなんです
日本のお寺に皆さんはよく文句言うでしょう
日本の坊主は全然信頼できませんよ
あれやこれやと 自分のことどうですかね
立派にいる よく言うこと
どう見たっても 今の日本のお寺の坊さんだってそれでも真面目にいますよ
日本の普通の社会と比較してみると
今も現代の社会と比較すると立派なんです
なので 人のことなら言いたい放題
自分のことは放っておいてくださいと
だから私が言うのは病気ですよと
治療してくださいと 病気で人がもがいている
叫んでいると そこに ならなくてもいいでしょう
その人はちょっと病気だから
なんとか治療しましょうっていうことでしょう
だから道徳破るっていうことは
これは恐ろしい精神病気なんです
危ないんです 発作を起こしたら人を殺して終わっちゃうんです
例えば 頭の中でも性的なことを妄想して電車に乗ってみて下さい
どうなるのか それ時点で病気でしょう
だから立派な人  NHK のね
かなり立派な人も痴漢したりして仕事クビになったりとかなるんだ
だからもうこの道徳的な思考がないっていうことはすごく気をつけた方がいいんです
これは精神病気だとした方が治りやすいんです
心が健全な人は当然人生を成功するんです
まあだから心思考がすごい健全で問題なく健康的だったら
人生は成功します でもそれから社会の問題
まああまり飛ばします
社会の問題は 人は道徳を守らないことですよ
社会でどんな問題があっても
簡単です 答えは道徳は守ってない
ただそれだけなんです
道徳を守らないからこそ
法律も警察も軍隊も その他の様々なシステムが必要ですよ
なんで軍隊が世の中に必要ですか？人は道徳を守らないんです
なんで警察が必要ですか？人は道徳を守らない
道徳を守るならば 何の社会問題もないでしょう
例えば子供たちにはもうもう学校から帰ると子供たちを守らなくちゃいけないんだとか
なんだあれは 子供たちは道知ってるでしょうに
学校から家まで だからブラブラブラブラよそ道をしながら
遊びながら ふざけながらゆっくり家に帰ればいいでしょうに
それこそ子供の人生でしょうに
学校から出たら動きそのままで公園に走ってきて
そこで遊んだりして まだどこかの他のところにグルッと行って
またそこでちょこちょこなんとかやって
もうやっともう母親がカンカン怒っている
ちょこちょこギリギリのところで家に入ると
それが美しい生き方なんです
そうじゃなくて 学校の終わるとずっと親たちがいて
じっと待って 子供一人一人そこまって
じーっと決まってる道で家に連れて行くという
なんでそういう社会になったんですかね
単純でしょ 道徳は守らない
学校の女の子も何人かも最近も殺されたでしょうに
そういうところが今 14歳になってくると
自分の子供のことも怖くならないと
危ないと怖いと 父親が別に自分の部屋で鍵かけて寝ないと
もう殺される可能性ありますよ
一人女の子がね 父親を殺したんだから
だからそこをガチャガチャガチャガチャと
誰が専門家何言ったってくだらないんですよ
基本的に社会が道徳を馬鹿にしているんだからなんです
日本の教育システムで一番全くも力いらない
何の人気もない授業って何ですかね
何か訳あって時間なくなったら先にカットされる授業って何ですかね
道徳の授業でしょ だって子供たちにも訳も分からない授業といえば何ですかね
それも道徳の授業なんです
何の説得力もないんです
私はいくつか調べたことはありますけど
道徳だと思いつつ とんでもない非道徳を教えるんです
道徳を教えようという番組が NHK でのなんとかチャンネルで流したんだけど
見たんですと そしたらこれって道徳じゃないでしょうにと
それにかかったお金とかかった専門家
もう平気で人の金かけてもう何千万もかけて非道徳を教える
しかし プロデューサーは知らない
プロデューサーはすごいいいこと言ってるつもり
だからこの社会では何か問題あるといえば
すべて道徳を守らんから起きる問題ですよ
貧困であろうか 何であろうと同じことなんです
貧富の差とかいろいろあるでしょ
石油の問題って何ですか？これは道徳守ってない
俺たちだけ儲ければいいや
だから先物取引でとにかくとにかく買って売って買っておく
それだけ 世界はどんな知ったことではないんだ
何のために個人がそれぐらい金を儲けなくちゃいけないんですかね
そこで随分豊かな国々っていうのは
俺たちの金だけだと思っているでしょう
だからそれの道徳違反でしょう
世界人類の財産ですよ
1 分ごとに子供が死んでいるでしょうに
食べ物がなくて なんでその子供たちに食わせないんですか？だから道徳さえあれば一切問題解決するんです
経済的には並ならぬダメージを受けてますよ
我々は だって人間の財産
全部道徳守らないんだから
そこを何とかするためにそれをなくしちゃいけないんです
貧困 飢えなどの問題も
道徳さえあれば起こらないんです
軍隊 軍隊とか警察とか
そういうシステムさえなければいらなくなったら
もう世界はすごいんですよ
だからもう道徳は大嫌いと言いつつ
しかし幸せになりたいと
そうすると狂暴な人以外は豊かにならないんです
それはいいでしょうかということなんです
それから宗教と道徳 道徳は宗教の所有物になっているんですね
勘違いですよ それ それは明白な道徳違反なんです
道徳というのは一人一人
人間がの正しい生き方なんですよ
道徳化取るのはそれは宗教の仕事だよ
それだったら信仰するグループだけ守るものになっちゃうでしょ
なんで宗教は道徳は自分一人だけのものなんですか？それこそ道徳違反ですよ
神を信じないことを否定することほど恐ろしい罪はないとまで言うんです
だから宗教から聞くと
道徳を教えてくれないんです
神を信じないことほど恐ろしい道徳罪がないんだよと言うんです
別に神を信じないというのは
ある一部のグループだけでしょう
だから道徳は自分たちだけの所有物になっている
そこは道徳じゃないんです
何かを信じる 勝手にすればいいんです
何かを信じること 道徳じゃないんです
それは だって何も信じたくない人はどうします？無神論者たちは非道徳的な人間だとするんです
それだけで社会で差別が生まれて道徳が破れる
我は神を信仰している
汝らは神を否定している
だから汝らは非道徳的だ
そこで社会で差別意識が生まれて
お互い喧嘩するんです
神を信じる人は自分たちが正しい正義の味方よ言って
無神論者たちを殺す 無神論者たちは神を信じることは間違っていると思って
神を信じる人々を殺す
そんなものですから 世界はね
道徳と何の関係もなく
もう非道徳の今の塊になっているんです
その宗教は道徳は一致しない
それから問題はたくさん宗教があるんですけど
道徳は一致しないんですね
だって宗教の所有物でしょ？何が正しいか一般人にはわからないんですね
イスラム教の道徳とは
イスラム教というのはユダヤ教のパクリですよ
神の言葉じゃないんです
で ユダヤ教とキリスト教のパクリで
なのに道徳違うんですね
キリスト教というのはユダヤ教のパクリで
なのにキリスト教とユダヤ教の道徳はそれぞれ違うんです
キリスト教にしたら カトリック教とプロテスタントの道徳はまた違う
どうすればいいんですかね
一般的に考えれば もう何言ってるのか
誰が正しいかさっぱりわからない
だから腰抜けの人は自信ない人は何かの組織に入って自由を失うしかないんです
それで幸せになれば幸せにならないんです
だから身の安全のことで
今ものすごくイスラム教が広がっているでしょう
みんなそれで軽々しくイスラムになっちゃうんです
その方が安全だと それだけでも非道徳でしょう
イスラム教批判したら殺されるんだったら
だったらその殺し屋の組織に入るんですかね
でもこれが何か一言言ったら
ものすごく世界的に危ないんですね
だからそれで素晴らしい教義だって言える？うかつに批判もできないんだから
そういうことで 宗教っていうのは非道徳の組織なんです
純粋に 断言して言います
皆様いろいろ色々あると思いますけど
宗教組織はありがたいとかね
宗教のおかげで道徳は理解不可能になっているようになっただけです
信仰を理由にして差別
弾圧 殺し 戦争 テロ行為までも起こるんです
だってわからないでどうするとは
ある人殺しは認めて ある人殺しは禁止する
それから政治と一緒になってものすごい迷惑をかけたでしょう
政治家と宗教一緒になっちゃうと
国民平等な政治ができないんですよ
まあ西洋の大体キリスト教かイスラム教でしょう
その国で他の宗教の人々もいるでしょうに
それに立場がないんです
隣のマレーシアにしたっても
もう国の宗教はもう国教はイスラム教で法律で他の宗教は禁止している
しかし 中国人も半分ぐらいいるし
インド人もいるし 仏教もあるし
ヒンドゥー教もあるし
みんな惨めで隠れていなくちゃいけないんです
公で差別とはいけないし
イスラム教の場合は必ずも宗教一緒でなければいけないと決めているんです
それこそ恐ろしいんです
西洋の場合はそれほど大きい問題はないけど
西洋もキリスト教と宗教一緒でしょうに
それでどれほど問題が起きているのかと
だから軽く考えると 政治家がある宗教を宗教にする国教にしちゃうと
国民は 100%同じ信仰ならいいんだけど
国民には別な信仰もあるし
信仰しない人もいるんだから
平等な政治ができなくなるんです
それが非道徳 それで平和がなくなってくるんです
では タイトル変えます
ブッダの批判 絶対的に神によって一切創造されたと信仰するならば
これパーリ語で一切ミンマーナワルというんです
殺生も盗みもよこしまな行為も
嘘も妄語 無言ですね 神の創造の結果です
絶対的に神がいて そこで創造せよと言った時点で
世界見ると人殺しがいる
それも神が創造した 盗人がいる
それも神が創造した よこしまな行為をする人がいる
それも神の創造です ということはどうなるんですかね
道徳を...罪を犯すなかれと言えないんですよ
人殺しで私は神様にそうやって何か目的がありまして
創造されたんだからということになるんです
そうなると道徳は成り立たないんです
これブッダの批判です
私ではありません 道徳を成立できない教えは初めからの邪見ですと
だからお釈迦様は道徳は成立できなかったら
それが邪見だよと なぜならば
道徳によって人間が幸福になるんです
人間が不幸になる教えだったら邪見でしょう
人は幸福にしてあげることが仕事でしょう
じゃあ親の仕事は何ですか？子供を幸福に育てることでしょう
旦那の仕事なんですかね
家族を幸福にしてあげることでしょう
じゃあ奥さんの仕事は？それまた家族を楽しい幸福にしてあげることでしょう
そう言って当たり前でしょう
そこを不幸にすることは非道徳ですよ
邪見ですよ 旦那が俺が仕事して給料もらったんだから
それは俺だけのお金ですよ
あげませんよ お前らに
思ったらそれで家族終わりでしょう
そんな仕舞いだったら
それは邪見に決まってるでしょ
だから人の幸福を壊すということは
道徳を成立できない ならば邪見だ
生命には運命があるのだ
自然法則で生きているのだなどなど考えもありますね
この科学者ぶってる人々とかね
すべて物質で説明してやるぞと
アミノ酸で一切の生命のことを説明してやるぞとか思ってて
道徳成り立たないんですよ
だって遺伝子の考え方を見れば
人殺したり もうもう女を犯したりする人と
まあやっぱりそういう遺伝子からという話でしょ
脳はそうなってるんだよ
だからそこは非道徳なんです
道徳は成り立たないんです
そんなくだらないインチキ話で
だからそれ一切の仏教ではない
邪見なんです あるいは運命で決まっているんだとか
何か言うと運命で決まってるんだったら
自分は運命によって生きているだけである
自己責任がなくなるんです
それで道徳は関係なくなっちゃう
それも邪見 それらの教えも道徳を否定するか
非道徳的な生き方に理由をつけるかですよ
だから道徳 人間の意志
努力などを否定する思考は
仏教は邪見だとするんです
道徳を否定すると邪見
人間の意志で判断することを否定しちゃうと邪見です
ブッダいうのは あなた考えて行動しているでしょう
あんた考えて自分の意志で喋ってるでしょ
喋らせてるわけないでしょ
歩かせてるわけないでしょ
自分で歩いてるんです
あの中国人がダチョウですとか
なんか鳥にあの足で餌を食わせるでしょ
首を取ってここまで麦を叩くんですね
叩いてぼーっと置いておくんです
そうすれば早く太らせて食べる
それで乾燥とかものすごく脂が乗って
それすごい高いお金で売れるんです
それで人がそれ食べて高いお金で食べて心臓発作起こして早く死ぬんです
で どこかで道徳を侵しちゃうと
次からずっと連鎖反応で侵すんですよ
だから道徳を侵して牛肉やら鶏やら作ってるんだから問題が起きてるんですよ
コレステロール問題も心臓の問題も脳出血の問題も
あれやこれやとかね 最初から道徳を侵してるんです
ちょっとしたほんのちょっとのことを食べますけど
量も少ないし 胃にはまだ足らないし
なのにそちらの 3ヶ月間分のコレステロール入ってるんです
脂肪が入ってるんです
体に悪い化学物質いっぱい入ってるんです
だから早く病気になるんです
道徳を守って自然に優しく
食べるならば そんなことはならないはずなんです
だから道徳を破ると どこから崩れていくか
完全に崩れていくんです
道徳っていうのは真理です
この真理っていう言葉をよく覚えておいてください
真理っていうのは誰にもどうすることもできない事実のことなんです
私が好きか嫌いか関係ないんですよ
私はよく出すのは地球が丸いという一言葉なんです
それで私がそれ好きであろうが
嫌いであろうが 私は知らないであろうが
関係ないでしょ ある意味ではだって宇宙船に乗っていろいろ飛行士たちがね
まあ写真撮ったりビデオ撮ったりしたことがありますけど
あれが丸く見えたんだから
でも私たちは行けないんだから
あれでは地球は丸いっていうことの証明になりませんけど
そんなこと言われたって丸いことは丸いでしょ
真理ってのはそういうことなんです
どうにもならん それに逆らうのはバカに決まってるんです
いまだに地球は平らやと言うならば
相当なものだとわかってもう決まってるでしょ
だから本当は道徳っていうのは真理なんです
残念ながらこの世で人間みんな本来道徳大反対人間だから誰も語ってなかったんです
それが問題 真理は誰も語ってなかったんです
みんな語ったのは 神が初めてアダムとイブとか
人間二人作ったんだよとか
そういう話なんです それからみんな親近創刊でしたっけ？単独ね
転身創刊でこの人類が生まれてるんだよと
もう科学から見たってもおかしいんですけど
遺伝はそこはダメということになってますけど
植物もそれはダメってことになってますけど
とにかく交配 交配 いろんなものを混ぜて混ぜて発展しているのは普通なんですよ
だから皆様にも手元にある道徳は
そういう人々が語ったものなんです
真理ではありません だから神様がすべて創った神様が汝に人殺すなかれと言ったと言ったら
それは非道徳です 神様が言おうか言わなかろうが関係なく
人殺しは悪いんだよと証明しなくちゃいけないんです
地球が丸いという感じで
地球が丸いと言ったら
犬にも猫にもミミズにも丸いんです
知っていようがなかろうが関係ないんです
我々は自然法則に従うしかないんです
例えば 人間が酸素を吸入しなくちゃいけないということは真理で事実でしょ
我々の細胞を維持するためには酸素が必要です
それが真理 真理 事実 個人好みは聞かないんです
信仰は関係ないんです
信仰あるか 無神論者であるか関係ないんです
みんな酸素入れなくちゃいけないんです
真理っていうのはそのレベルのものなんです
従うしか道がない 従わなかったら逆らったらあなた一人で死ねということです
あんた不幸になります
だから私は酸素嫌いだと言って
私は窒素を吸います 吸ってみてください
勝手に 道徳っていうのはそんなレベルのものなんです
犯したら必ず悪い結果が来るんです
それを知ってる人は 間違っても夢の中ででも道徳は違反しません
夢の中でも悪いことをしない
その時でも あ これはダメということです
それはやるもんじゃない
それぐらいの説得力で
迫力で 真理として 科学の授業みたいな感じで道徳を教えられたことがありますかと
教わったことはありますかと
私にも説教された時ありますからね
うちはもうカトリック教の学校だから
すごい道徳には厳しいんだよと
なんか私をバカにしているような感じで
カトリック教の学校で教えてくれるのは道徳ですけど
私が聞きたいんですって
だから結局は私はすごい気楽に生活できてますけど
どこでも何のこともなく
自由自在 他の人々にはできないでしょう
怯えて自信がない 緊張しちゃって
なんで？これ道徳の問題なんです
ワンシー私は何か文句ある？という態度で生活できるんです
全然もう意地にも緊張も何もしない
どんな批判があったってびくともしない
なぜですか？これは道徳の問題です
じゃあ言ってみて 言ったら言った人はまずかったと思うことにはなります
蛇の罠に俺が手を出したんだからという
もう文句言えません 蛇に噛まれます
ですから この道徳は真理ですということをまず覚えてください
道徳真理とは一時的な考え
価値観ではありませんということのです
因果法則ということのです
因果法則は客観的な真理
事実なのです 因縁とその結果をよく調べて
好まない結果を出す原因と好む結果を出す原因を語るとは道徳倫理なのです
はい これが仏教の立場なんです
道徳倫理っていうのは
因果法則をしっかり調べて
しっかりと調べて研究している
好む結果はこういう原因で現れるんだ
好ましくない結果はこういう原因で現れるものだと
その原因を教えてくれるのです
そうすると我々のは判断する
我々は完全に一つだけ正解しかないんだからね
あ 幸福になりたいのは当たり前
ですから 私は幸福になる原因を選んで
不幸になる原因を避けると
そこが道徳世界なんです
だからうかつに道徳は語れません
誰にでも語れるものじゃないんです
みんなそう思ってるでしょ
道徳ぐらいは俺が教えてやるぞと
車の運転はそれは講習所で専門家がやるんだよと
えらいあべこべなんですよ
車の運転するぐらいはどんな馬鹿にもできますよ
だってこういう私も車の運転したこともないんです
しかし 一人の男の子にちゃんと運転の仕方を教えて
もう自分の国では一人第一人者ぐらい言えるほど腕がいいんです
一応あいつは車を触ったり
自分で触ったり いろいろやったりしたし
政府の免許も取ったり取ってても運転最悪
それから私は正しい運転ってどういうものなのかと
一緒に車で運転しながら間違い起こすたびに
こういうとこはあんたこういうことがあってこういうことでいたんだよと
で クラクション鳴ったら
お前ね それは落ち着いてないっていうことよ
あの車を追い起こしたければ
あなたの自分の腕の能力でそれをやらなくちゃいけないし
しかし 前に運転する車には微塵も邪魔してはならないんだ
その人は気付かず 気付かず
サッと前に行ったら あれ怖い
それでここは一発で終わるんです
その一回行っただけで
一生一生クラクション鳴らした
スリランカで運転運転してっていうのは
みんなクラクション鳴らさなきゃ車動かないぐらい思ってるんです
それぐらいうるさいんです
で その子の影響で かなり他の運転するやってる人々も
これどんどんどんどんやめていくんですよ
そういうことで 私が言いたいのは
それぐらい私にも教えられます
自分では車を 1 メートル前先に持っていくこともできないんです
やったこともないし だから世界はあべこべなんです
道徳を教えることは一番難しいんです
原子爆弾の組み立てなんかイラン人にもできるし
北朝鮮にもできるでしょ
しかし 国民を守ることはできないでしょ
その人々に ここみんなお腹いっぱいご飯食べて幸せにいられることできないでしょ
みんな気持ちよく 楽しく
怯えがなく 生活すること
そこできないでしょ 原子爆弾作るわ
ロケット作るわと わかるでしょ？どんな馬鹿にもできますよ
そんな簡単なことは あのアホの国にできないのは
周りの国々とどうすれば平和で仲良く一緒に生活できるのか
自然災害で食料とかなんとなくなったら
みんな心配してみんな協力してくれるような環境はどう作ればいいか
それわからないでしょ
それが道徳の世界なんです
人を幸福にすること だから冗談じゃないんですよ
この話は 世界はあべこべなんです
どんな馬鹿にもできることはすごいことだと言っていて
誰にもできないことはどんな馬鹿にもできると思っているんです
では 私は皆様に挑戦します
人殺してはならないと思ってるでしょ？じゃあなぜ？答えてみてください
説得力ある 否定できない
異論成り立たない答えを出してみてください
できることをなら 従って
智慧の完成者にしか道徳を完全に語れないんです
ですから 因果法則を知り尽くして
知るべきものは知り尽くして
智慧を完成した人しか道徳わからないのです
なのに道徳は生きているものに誰にでも必要なんです
犬にも必要なんです 猿の群れにも必要なんです
道徳破るとそれで終わりですよ
壊れて壊れていくんです
しかし これがブッダしか知らないということはいかに大変か
これであの別なポイント
2つの側面がありますね
道徳には 自分と社会との関わり
そこで道徳は機能する
自分の心の動き この 2つに道徳は機能するんです
で  2つの側面で道徳を理解するんです
この両方に正しい仕方をしなくてはならないんですね
幸福をもたらす行為は正しい行為だと定義するんです
それでお釈迦様の定義は幸福をもたらす行為が道徳だよ
その定義なら皆様道徳は嫌いだよと言いました
みんな道徳嫌いだと思うことにも一理ありますよ
なぜ宗教が言うんだから
学校の先生が言うんだから
あれやるな これやるな
だから嫌いって言いますよ
それで理由を聞いたら理由がわからないんですね
嘘をつくな言ったけど
嘘をついて何が悪いんでしょうか？と聞いたらよくわからない
お寺に行ったら嘘をつかないでと言ったら
変な答え出すんです 地獄に落ちますよ
地獄ありますかね？俺はわかりませんよでいいですね
だからあんたは地獄あることわからない人がそんなこと言うなよということになるんです
嘘をつかないでいる人は天国に行くんだよと
天国あるんですかね？わかりません
ということでしょう だったらうるさいこと言わないで
いいえ そんなことはこのテキストにありますよ
テキスト捨てて捨てちゃえば話終わりでしょう
聖書にある聖書は燃やしちゃえ
もし聖書がなければ人類みんな死のんだぞと言ったら
燃やすわけにはいきませんね
だからいらないものは捨てても結構でないでしょう
そういうことです テキストで言えば
だから定義があるんですよ
幸福になる方法が道徳です
そういう簡潔たる言葉で人類には喋れませんよ
じゃあ幸福になる方法はいやでしょうか
幸福になりたくないでしょうか
それはもう頭が完璧に悪い人以外はどうにもならん
どうにもならんですよ
私は幸福になるのは嫌ですよということは成り立ちません
幸福になる方法は間違っているんだよということは成り立ちません
ですから 道徳の定義は幸福になる道ということです
それは 2つの側面で考えるんですね
社会と道徳  1番目の側面
人は一人勝手に勝手では生きること
生きることさえもできないんです
一人勝手には 今まで生きてきたということは
無数に他人 無数の他人に他人のお世話に
お世話を受けた 協力をしてもらったと
ということ 一人では生きることさえできないんです
生命には自給自足という能力はないんです
外からいろんなものをいただかないとダメなんです
ですから 今まで生きてきたということは
無数の生命に助けてもらったことなんです
この体も知識も その他の持ち物も他人から得たものです
体も他人からもらった
他人からもらうもので体を成長したんです
知識は他人からもらったんです
皆様喋る日本語は生まれつきついた
カラスはカーカー鳴いてるでしょ
そんな感じで ないでしょう
他人から教えてもらったんです
調子に乗るんじゃないんです
じゃあ持ち物は？服 家
家具 パソコンなどなど
全部他人から 自分持ってきたってことはない
ほとんどないんです ないんです
そういうこと それでそこで道徳成り立つのです
他人に嫌われない 批判されない
攻撃を受けない生き方
他人が認める生き方 協力してしたくなる生き方
他人が自分に協力したくなる生き方
他人が必要とする生き方が道徳的な生き方になるんです
異論がありますか？あなたはすべて他人のものです
だから他人に好まれ 好かれた方がいいんじゃないの
他人があの人を助けてあげなくちゃどうしようもないというふうに思わせる生き方したら悪い
他人が あの人はよく頑張ってます
真面目 立派と認める生き方が悪い
異論成り立ちませんよ
ちゃんと客観的に調べてみると
だから社会と自分の関係で
社会はいかに自分を容認するかということなんです
だから嘘つくなと言うんですよ
別に単純に 嘘をつけたら社会が嫌いでしょうね
騙される 私があなたを助けて生かしてあげているのに
私を騙すってどういうことかっていう話でしょ
私というのは社会のこと
社会がお前を生かしているのに
お前が社会を嘘ついて騙す
だったら死にます 死になさいということになるわけです
そういうことで嘘をついてはいけないし
盗んではいけないし 邪な行為してはいけないし
勉強しないでいってはいけないし
試験ごまかしてはいけないし
カニングしてはいけないんです
今 最近 どこかの教育関係でね
いろいろ裏で話してお金あげたりしてね
まあいろいろやっている話が出ていますけどもね
信じられないことよくやりますね
それにまた宗教嫌い 仏教嫌い
堂々と言いながら この国は自分たちやることなんですかね
情けないでしょ 世界で大国家として
それで面子立てますかね
そんなことやれば だから自分で恥かいてるでしょ
道徳を否定すること  それも怒る必要はないし
やっぱり道徳は知らないということだから
ブッダに厳しくはないんです
ブッダならそういうふうに教えるんです
では文句ありますかと
あなたには あなたはまず科学的に自分の人生見なさいよ
これ借り物だと だったら貸してあげた人に親切せせなさいよ
だから仏教から見れば
自然を守ることも道徳
動物の生き方を守ってあげることも道徳
道徳 この地球上で微生物にも道徳的に生きられる環境を作ることも道徳
微生物がなければ我々死にますからね
食品のラベルを変えないことも道徳
中身のそのままラベル貼らないと嘘なんですよ
そんなことは法律では決めることですかね
そこまで道徳壊れてるんですか？食品にラベルを貼る場合は中身を表示しなさいと
バカバカしいでしょう
ラベルって当たり前でしょ
これこれ入ってるんだけど
産地はこういうところだよと書くの
それが法律で決めないと見ないじゃないんですね
賞味期限 期限 法律で定めていないと書けないんです
そういうわけで 道徳っていうのは当たり前のことで
人のおかげで生きているんだから
食品会社が一般人が買って食べるんだから
自分が 幸せになっているでしょう
だったら 食べる人々には美味しいもの
健康に体にいいものを食べさせる義務が生じているでしょう
だからそういう人々には会社経営する資格は全くないんです
金がない 金がもらう資格もないんです
資格もないんです はっきり言えば
生きる権利を失っているんです
私たちは奪ったわけじゃないんです
本人が捨てたんです 生きる権利を
不窃盗 盗まないこと 嘘をつかないことなどは社会に他人に対する親切な行為なんですよ
せっかく自分にご飯作ってくれる人のご飯を手にとって
そのままぶん殴るということは
やっぱり正しくないでしょ
恩を知る恩返しの行為です
だから社会に対する道徳というのは
単純に恩を知ること 恩返しということなんです
生きているなら当然行うべき行為です
心の働きで道徳の次の側面
人は考えて行動するんです
一切の行為はその人の考えの結果です
感情の衝動で考えることもしないで行動する
しかし 我々は感情で怒って行動する
考えることしない 欲で行動する
もう何も考えない 考えさえも感情も汚れているならば
間違っているならば 社会に多大な迷惑をかける悪行為をしていることになるんです
たとえ私が散歩を歩いたっても
散歩を歩いたいという考えがあるんです
たとえ私が手を挙げてこうやって頭をかいでも
頭がかゆい かかなくちゃという考えがあります
もしその考えが汚れているならばどうしますか？ はい
行為が悪行為になるんです
他人の迷惑になるんです
自分の迷惑になるんです
例えば感情でいろんなことをやるでしょうに
もしその感情が汚れているならばどうしますか？悪行為になるんです
我が心を清らかにすることが道徳です
ですから 手っ取り早いのは我が心を清らかにするんです
それで安心です 心はきれいだから
何考えても考えが綺麗です
心が清らかになったら
どんな感情を起こしたっても
その感情がすごく美しいんです
綺麗です はい そういうわけで
完全な道徳 自分だけ幸福になる行為は不完全ですね
それは自我ですからね
他人が不幸になる恐れがあるんです
周りだけが幸福になる行為も不完全です
自分も他人も不幸になる恐れがあります
周り 周りを幸福にしようと頑張る
ちょっと不完全です それは自分が不幸になる可能性あります
他の人々が不幸になる可能性あります
他人だけ幸福になる行為も不完全です
自分と周りが犠牲になる恐れがあります
じゃあ他人様を幸福にしてあげようと思っちゃうと
これ危ないんです 自分と周りが犠牲になる可能性あります
自分も周りも他人も幸福になる行為は完全な道徳です
これはもう断然的に絶対的な道徳です
誰にも否定できません
たとえ神が来ても たとえバラモンさんが来ても
梵天神が来ても否定できません
ブッダがそういう完全なる道徳なんですよ
語っています 項目的には十悪といって
やめるものはね 守るものは十善という
同じことですよ 殺生してはいけないし
盗んではいけないし 盗むという言葉を使わないんです
与えられてないものは取ってはいけないし
すごく言葉に気をつけるんです
ものすごい深い意味なんです
盗むということはあまり正しくないんです
盗む場合は それを人がいなきゃ盗みにならないんです
そうじゃなくて 与えられてないもの
与えられてないものっていうのは
自分に使用する権利がないもの
だからすべて他人からもらうものでしょ
体が 他人がはい どうぞ使ってくださいと言わなくちゃあかんですよ
生命は だから自分に使用する権利ないものを使用しようとすることが
仏教でいう盗めなんです
だから盗みという単語を使わないんです
与えられてないものを取ることが盗みであると言うんです
それからこの不材とかね
欲しがな行為についても
また日本語の単語正しくないんです
仏教は正しい単語を使っています
残念ながら誰も直訳しようとしないんですね
正しい直訳は 欲については
間違った行為をしてはならないということなんです
この欲って何でしょうかって聞いちゃうと
生きる時は我々は依存するんですね
目に入るものに 耳に入るものに
体に触れるものに 舌に味に
嗅ぐものに この五つに依存して生きているんです
これが楽しいんですよ
いろんなものを見ると楽しい
いろんな音を聞くと楽しい
いろんな味を味わうと楽しい
いろんな香りを嗅ぐと楽しい
体でいろいろ観測を受けると気持ちよくて楽しい
それで人々は楽しいんだから
間違った方法ででも得ようとするんです
それをやめなさいと それが日本訳になると
欲しない行為ということになっています
けど お釈迦様がすごい見事な完璧な言葉でたちに語っているはずなんです
語っているんです で 嘘を言ってはいけないし
悪口言ってはいけないし
無駄話はいけないし それから寝まいしたらよくないし
それから精神的な病気で生まれる怒り
欲 いわゆる根拠のない怒り
欲は完全ダメであると
頭のところですね お腹が空いてもううどん食べたいなと思うのは道徳違反じゃないんです
根拠もなく あれ欲しい
これ欲しい ああなりたい
こうなりたい 世界一美人になりたい
と思っちゃうと それが道徳違反なんです
根拠ないんです 旦那さんに聞いたら
正直なところはもっと可愛い女がいたんだからと言うんですね
だから そういうことで自分がまた世界一になろうと思っちゃうとね
それ病気になるんですね
それから 根拠のないあの秋葉原事件を起こした人みたいに
もうみんなのことを恨んだり憎んだり
誰も何も悪いこと言ってないのに
そういう根拠のない怒り
その 2つの 9番目の罪で
邪見が 10番目で一番重い罪なんです
だから一番軽い罪は殺生
一番重い罪は邪見です
順番も順番で素晴らしいです
なぜならば 邪見そのもので全ての不悟が生まれるんです
だから道徳を守りたい人はややこしい
そんな道徳を守ると思ったら
邪見それをなくしちゃえばいいんです
邪見正見にすればもう道徳な人間なんです
だから守るのは簡単に守れるようにしてあるんです
はい 道徳 それでお釈迦様は終わらないんですよ
道徳を守れではないんです
道徳からも自由になりなさいと言っているんです
殺生する気持ちがあるなら
不殺生は道徳になるんです
道徳もやっぱり自由じゃないんです
人を殺したいと気持ちあると
私は人を殺してはいけませんで
道徳を守らなくちゃいけないんです
人のものを盗みたいと気持ちあると
盗んではならないと厳しく守らなくちゃいけなくなるんです
盗む気持ち毛頭ない人は
え？と思うだけ 人のものを盗らないよだからその人は初めからそんな気持ちは毛頭ないんです
その人が道徳ならないんですよ
だから道徳を守らなくちゃということで
結構自由がないんですよ
盗む気持ち 欲があるから盗まないことは道徳になるんです
だから欲があるんだから道徳は成り立つんですね
要するに心が汚れているからこそ道徳が成り立つんです
答えは簡単 あなたの心が汚れているんだから
あなたには道徳は欠かせませんよと
だから当然守る時はかなり苦しいんだよと思いますよ
心の汚れと戦わなくちゃいけないんです
心は完全に清らかになると
非道徳はもとより道徳も超異するんです
では 心は完全に綺麗になったらどうなるんですかね？道徳からも自由になるんです
もう非道徳は起こりません
起こりもしない  そういうことで
お釈迦様は道徳を語るよりは
完全たる道徳と道徳からの自由というような形でです
もしかするとそれで終わりと思います
終わりです あ では 最後のスライドだけ出してもらって
はい そういうことで 道徳の話は終了する
もうちょっと説明します
なんで道徳と智慧が 一体でしょうかと
一体になるんで 例えば人が殺せないという道徳だけ守る
1個だけです 殺せないということは
もう殺したい気持ちはあるんだからでしょ
道徳は殺したいんだけど
我慢して殺さないことにするんですよ
蚊が刺したら顔をぶつけたい
もう潰しちゃいんだけど
やっぱり殺さないと決めたんだから
なんとか自分逃げますよとかね
蚊を殺さない そういう風に自分が心の中で戦いをするんです
自分の悪い気持ちと戦って
良い気持ちを勝つようにするんです
そこでその人は毎回毎回苦しむでしょう
毎回毎回苦しむんです
殺さないでいるたびに
それでどんどんやっぱり自分がこの怒りあるんだから人を憎しむんだから
こんなひどい苦しんでるんだと
ではもう怒りをなくそうと
生命は慈しもうと みんな可愛いと思っちゃおうと
それで楽になるんです
それで智慧があるんだ
生命は平等であると みんな生きる権利があるんだ
わがままは成り立ちませんよ
殺したいという気持ちが自分のエゴである
エゴがない方が正しい
すると智慧が現れるんです
智慧が現れた道徳が完成するんです
道徳が完成すると智慧が現れるんです
智慧が完成するんです
だから道徳と智慧がワンセットなんです
同じコインの裏と表なんです
一つだけ取ることはできないんです
そういうわけで 道徳を守る意思あるんですよ
道徳的になった時点でもう頭が回転
もう回転するんです 頭が冴えてきます
だからですよ 道徳を守る人は大成功を収めるのは頭がいいんです
失敗しないんです 何でも成功するんです
そういうことで 成功の鍵
秘密の鍵は道徳に鍵なんです
以上です どうもありがとうございます
それでは これよりせっかくの機会ですので
質疑応答の時間を設けさせていただきたいと思います
長老へのご質問がございましたら
手を挙げていただけますでしょうか
はい お渡しいたします
えっと もう初めて参加させていただいたんですけれども
質問の 1点してもよろしいでしょうか？ すみません
私は失礼いたしました
はい あの  ちょっと待ってください
大阪在住でいいんですけれども
スリランカの方に日本人は道徳がないということを教えていただいて
なんか日本人としてすごく恥ずかしいなと思ったんですけれども
長老はお父さんお母さん会われましたか？えっ
お会いなくて お父さんお母さんに対してはどういう気持ちでいられますか？ 尊敬できますけど
そうですか ありがとうございます
えっと 日本人として親を敬うとかっていうのは道徳だと思うんですけど
それに対して長老はどう思われますか？ それは当然ですよ
それと私 今回参加させていただいたのは
ブッダお釈迦様大好きなんですけれども
長老はお釈迦様に会われたことはありますか？私は生まれて 65年だからね
弥勒が出てにも 2000年
500年  60年経っています
530 年経ってますけど
会ってないんで  会われてませんか？ どうやって読むんですか？私
生まれる 2000年前に亡くなられたから
会われてないのに どうしてブッダがいいとか言えるんですか？どうして証明できるんですか？ じゃあ
あんた 縄文時代は日本の歴史生きてます？ あの
私はお釈迦様に  私は必要に答えてます
あんた日本の歴史の中で縄文時代っていうことはあったことを知ってます
あ 学校でしか習ってませんけれども
でも今日長老が言われたブッダの言葉というのは
お釈迦様が言われた本当の言葉なんでしょうか
そうです  どうして言っているんでしょうか
そうだからですよ  私も長老が言われるように
道徳っていうのはすごく大事だと思うんです
あの さっき言われた 道徳と知恵
自分が先に実行してから他人に指導する
指導する賢者になりなさいということが言われたんですけれども
知恵というのは お釈迦様からいただく知恵だと思うんですけれど
私はお釈迦様からそう教えていただいたんですけれど
なぜスリランカからこちらに道徳
日本人に道徳を 道徳が大切なのを教えに来られたんですか？ あんたみたいな人間がいるんだから
かもしれません こんなとして
こんなして出しゃばって言って恥ずかしいなとは思うんですけれども
自分にとってお釈迦様の教えが間違った方向でいくのは見ていてつらく
つい出しました 申し訳ございませんでした
皆さんすいません  だから私がお釈迦様の教えを間違っていったとあんた思っているならば
それを言ってください
怒りを汲んで お寺のお坊さんとかキリストさん
それをけなすこともお釈迦様は望んでないと思われます
それぞれあなた思っても
極端に悪いことは私はだからはっきり言ったんです
これお釈迦様おっしゃったんだよ
人を思いやる気持ちが大切だと思います
人それぞれ考え方があって
その考え  人を思いやるって言ったって
人が間違ってやっていることは正さない
正すことが思いやりなんです
人を思いやるということは
何でもいいやっていういい加減な中途半端な言い方じゃないんです
人間というのは生まれつきもう不完全ですよ
だからそこはあれですよ
いろいろやきばしい育てなきゃいけないんです
それが思いやりなんですよ
子供が何か悪いことをしたらやめなさいと言うのは
それ思いやりなんです
まあ関係ない 子供は子供だから何もわからないんだからとかね
放っておこうとか それ思いやりじゃないんです
母親が今の現代の子供たちに何でもやってあげて
やってあげて 子供の奴隷ですね
それが思いやりじゃないんですよ
子供は自立できない悪人
犯罪者を育てるんですよ
思いやりっていうのは
厳しい時は厳しくするんです
だから世界中 神を信仰する人でことで
歴史的に人類は苦労してきたんですよ
今もテロ行為起きてるんですよ
地球が丸いと言った人は殺しちゃったんですよ
聖書に反対したんだからという何考えてるんですかね
悪いことは悪いと言うことが
はい 正しいと思います
長老がおっしゃるのは
でも親は親の姿を子供に見せて育てていくものだと思います
一人一人他人に怒りを含んで化ボス怒りを含んで化ボスということはなかなかできないと思います
相手を思いやって化ボスっていうのが大事だと思うんです
自分の良心を大事にしている姿を子供に見せていれば
それは根本の道徳になると思うんです
それはそれで結構ですけど
だから質問になり方ないでしょう
質問じゃなくて その  質問にならないと言ったんです
申し訳ございません 長老を怒らせてしまって本当に
私は怒らせることはできませんよ
先ほどからかなり何か怒られているような気が
それは私のスタイルなんです
あ そうなんですね 私 怒られていると
私を怒らせると思う調子にならない方がいいんです
申し訳ございません とりあえずあの変な質問
そんな野蛮な人間だったら
この世界に向けてそういう風に堂々と喋れるわけないでしょうに
だと思います だけど お釈迦様の考え方っていうのをちゃんと知ってほしいです
あまりにも生ぬるく喋ると
もう心は刺激を受けないんですよ
ちょっと聞きます  ただダラダラと仏話を聞くんだから
時間がかかります  いいですか？ まあもう
まだ  他にご質問ございますでしょうか
あの前 ここの講義で長老はみんな脳細胞をたくさん持っているのに
ほとんど使っていない
脳細胞をたくさん持っているのに
だから我々僧侶は仏教を伝えるのにとても苦労する
そして日本の僧侶はみんなに分かりやすく伝えるために
仏教をいろんな形で伝えた結果が大乗仏教であるとおっしゃって
それはいろんなことに言うと思うんですけれども
真実をほとんどの人は知りたがりません
で 分かりやすいように
その人に合わせて真実を説明しようとすると
いつの間にか真実を曲げて伝えることになるはずです
どうすればお釈迦様のようにお釈迦様のバラモンに自分から言わせたように
真理を一歩も曲げない
けれども相手の気持ちも傷つけないで真理を悟らせるという説明の仕方を自分ができるようになるには
どういうことを心がけていけばいいか教えてください
うんうん これとても難しいんですよ
だから人に合わせるとおっしゃった通りに
いろんなことを言えなくなっちゃったんですね
そうすると真理を曲げたことにもなるし
お釈迦様はソウダンダバラモンと行った対話形式みたいに
そこを読んでみると なるほど
そういうやり方があるんだとわかるんだけど
そこは我々にかかってくると
もうあんまりうまくいかないんですよ
だからまあ 仏教の歴史の中でも
まあそれは完全な方法だと知ってるんですけど
諦めているんですね できる範囲ではやりますけど
できない時もあります
だからこの 我々はできるだけでお互い思いやりということがあって
もう理解し合って 理解し合って
お互いに勉強しましょうという気分でいかなきゃいけないと思いますね
お互いに勉強しましょう
しましょうよと 例えばもう私の場合でも
俺はこうだからというよりも
私はこれはこうだからいいと思いますけど
いかがでしょうか  2人でやってみましょうと
やる気になるんですよ
あんまりわかりませんだけど
やってみましょうと 言うと
なるほど じゃあ2人でやりましょうという気分になっちゃうんですね
前の質問した方と同じ質問ね
結構受けたことありましてね
まあブッダの教えも間違っているんだ
だからどうやってと言ったら
自分信仰しているブッダが今いるんだよと
だからまあそれはその人
自分でブッダと言うし
歴史的には我々はお釈迦様
ブッダって言うんだよ
それでいいんじゃないかと
いえいえ あなたがたは間違っているんだと
だからどうやって言うのかと
私はそう思いますよ ああ
そう で そういう話終わったんです
自分もそう思うんだったら
いいです それで話終わり
だからまあ喧嘩することもできないし
対応することもできなくなっちゃうんですね
まあポイントはね やっぱり一番正しい方法っていうのは相手から答えを出すことなんですね
しかし 私たちにとっては
この真理をすべて教えるということは当然できないし
人を悟らせあげるということもできないし
我々にできるのは立派な社会人にしてあげることぐらいでしょうね
だから仕事に行きたくないと言ったら
仕事をしないことで幸せになるのでしょうかと
相手に で あんたは不幸に不幸になるでしょ
不幸になる覚悟でいるのかと
不幸はいいと思ってますか？と
なんで仕事行けないのかと聞いたら
仕事は苦しいんだと では
あなたは人類がみんな楽しいんだから仕事をしているんだということを知ってますかと
仕事私もしていますけど
すごく苦しいんだよ お父さんもしているし
他の人もしている みんな苦しいんだよと
だからあなたは好きな仕事だったらやろうと思ったって
じゃああんた調べたことがありますか？と
楽々で楽しく仕事をする人がいるんだと
あ いますよと相手言ったら
ではあなたはそういう楽な仕事をなんで探さないのかとかね
そういう風な過程で持っていかなくちゃいけないんですね
それはダメだ 仕事に行きなさいよ
何するのかとかね そういうことですから
ちょっと対話形式で持っていかなくちゃいけない
しかし 私たちには完璧にできるとは思えないんですね
ブッダのシステムは しかし
ある程度で真似た方がいいんです
いわゆる人の性格にぴったし合ってアドバイスできる能力はブッダにしかなかったという
我々も伝説的にはそう思っているんです
誰にもなかった だからイエス様はなんで殺されたのかというと
口が悪かったんです あれほど大胆に批判していたのに
お釈迦様は尊敬されたんです
バラモン主義の 言い方なんです
もうできるだけ頑張ってみるということですよ
うまくいかなかったらうまくいかなかったでね
ありがとうございました
えーと 時間もありますので
ではあと一つ 一つ質問をお受けしたいと思いますけれども
どなたかございますでしょうか
なければ昼食に はい はい
マイク マイク  今日はありがとうございました
あのすごい素朴な質問なんですけれども
例えば あの まあ道徳を守ることが幸せになる方法だな
真だということなんですが
例えばもう私は幸せにならなくてもいいと
例えば そのちょっとやけくそ気味の人間がいたとした場合
どのような その説を言いますか
鑑賞したらいいとお考えになるでしょうか
うん まあそれってね ケースバイケースでしょうし
論理的なところはね 私は幸せにならなくてもいいという人がなんで生きてるんですか？というね
だからその時点で矛盾なんですよ
あんた不幸になる呼吸やめてください
すごい不幸になりますよと
呼吸しなくても幸せなんかいらんというのはね
いるんですよ そういう人
結構実際にはね だからもう矛盾もいいところですよ
だから理論的なところで言えば
だったらあんた なんで 10 分とかね
15 分とか呼吸を止めていないんでしょうかと
結構不幸になりますよ
だからその時点で本人がもう恐ろしい矛盾を言ってるんですよ
自分でご飯を食べてるくせに
自分がお風呂に入ってるくせに
自分がテレビを見ているくせに
幸せになんかなりたくはないんだ
だからそういうところを教えてあげればなんとかなるんじゃないかなと
いい加減にしろよと そこまで嘘を言うなよと
我々は商売のことで ちょくちょく家庭の平和のためにも
奥さんにちょこちょこと嘘を言ったりとはしますけど
そこまでは嘘は言いませんよと
普通だったら不倫したっても
奥さんにバレたらまずいんだから
それはとにかく誤魔化して誤魔化してとかね
やっぱり悪いことは悪いんだけど
まあそれもやってることも嘘をついてるんですけど
やっぱり家族だけは破りにも不幸にしたくないというぐらいの気持ちはあるんですよ
だからまあそんなにすごい極限の嘘ってことにならないんです
ああいう人々は極限の嘘を言ってるんですよ
そこまで嘘を言うのかと
だから結構いるんですよ
不幸にはなりたくはないとか
私が受けたケースなんですけど
まあ実際に瞑想をしようと思っていて
頑張ってみて あの本人が瞑想をしたら
やっぱり自分の心見えてきたんですね
心見えてきたら 自分が自分でずっと自分をいじめていじめて苦しんでいることが分かったんですね
次のステップはそこを思考をやめることなんですね
しかし 本人のもう力尽きちゃって
それ以上は瞑想を進めないんです
まあ進みますけど 本人が進めないと思っている
それで私が言うのは やっぱり私は幸福になりたくないかも
もしかすると で そこは嘘じゃないんですね
本人がやっぱり妄想をやめようとやめようとしたんだけど
なかなかやめられない
後で発見したが 自分が好んで妄想しているということ
しかし 妄想するたびに不幸になる
不幸になるのにまた好んで妄想すると
ということは 私は幸福になりたくないんじゃないかという論理的な答えなんですね
だから そのような立派な人々には別な答えがあるんです
私の答えは あなたは幸福になりたくないんじゃなくて
ただくし抜けでしょうと
ただ頑張っても頑張っても
もうもうこれ以上できないと諦めただけでしょうと
諦めろよと それだけなんです
その場合は それからもう一つケースがあるんですよ
この人をいじめることは好きで
いわゆる快感で そういう恐ろしい鬼の性格ですね
で 自分もこの殴られるのは好きで
快感でとかね そういう苦しみを快感で繰り返する人々もいるんですね
しかし それは快感でしょうかね
...惨めで 時々精神的な病気の人だと
私はダメな人間だとか被害妄想を持ったりするでしょ
だからずっと被害者のヘロ
ヒーローを演じてるんですね
だから社会ででもいいことがあっても
自分がすぐもうそこは悲観的にとって
もう被害者になっちゃうんですね
この被害妄想とかね それも本人が喜んでやっているんですね
だからなかなか治りにくいんですね
そういう人々もいる それも精神的な病気であって
本来は幸福になりたいんですよ
幸福になりたいんだから
この恐ろしいことを快感として勘違いしたりする
だから 美味しいご飯 うなぎ食べたいという人が
そこら辺の店に陳列されていたプラスチックで作っている食品の形あるんですね
それを取って食べたような感じなんです
食べたらやっぱりこれうなぎでしょ
形も似てるでしょ だからこれでいいやと思って食べたのは食べたんですけど
あれプラスチックでできてるものだから
それからひどい目に遭ったりはします
だからそれで栄養を取ったことになりません
だから自分をいじめて他人をいじめて
その刺激が好きで 我々の話なんかはとんでもない
私はそんな幸福は嫌やという人々はそういう程度なんですね
後でまずかったと思う羽目にはなります
とにかく この極限に邪見に陥っている人っていうのは
すごく治りにくいんですよ
いくらでも屁理屈を持ってくる
はい ありがとうございました
ありがとうございました
では これをもちまして
アルバムでスマナサーラ長老による講演会の部を終了させていただきます
長老 どうもありがとうございました
ありがとうございました
[applause]